it seemed like spring
it was 40
degrees windy and then i got out of the
is
um
by two different guys
it's a maze yeah no it's also i've got
i got him on my right so i know where i
am i got you on my left and i think
where am i
yeah we didn't we didn't count right
when we came down the table did we
no problem getting fresh air with that
wind
now who are we missing though
always late that was why i brought that
up to the day it's a real problem
because
bang bang a lot of these are one vote
but like lucy said he can't do anything
yeah basically the reason i called john
is i wanted to make sure i was accurate
with what i wrote for a committee report
so i wanted to make sure what was going
on with that then i had this
conversation i said well this doesn't
make any sense then
so i kept digging into it and then as i
called him he said i'm not going to
change my vote even if the other one
environment does that and i said okay
this is never going to go any further
but then when we got even more data it
became even more confusing so i thought
i'd bring you into the loop but i didn't
call you last night because i didn't
need to burden you if he wasn't going to
change we weren't having the votes it
didn't matter so
right so i was basically i was doing is
for my mobile office while driving and
then after i got home and then trying to
write the report and making sure that
i'm not saying something that's not
correct
is
even though it's really kind of a flaw
in the law
even though you have a policy to take
off here
well what it means is they're not
enforced the hhs is not enforcing
because it says they must enforce that
policy my ideas if my policy is i don't
this is the health and human services
committee in exile
from our previous room and there was no
truth to the fact we were thrown out
um and there's no truth to the fact that
we caused damage which led to being
thrown out
simply finance wanted their room back
and we thought that was only fair
thank you to those of you including a
few of you in the wee hours of the
morning who sent your reports to me
because i have to get them in by
wednesday
at noon
so i am going to
um ask that
if you move a bill
or if you are the minority
report writer
you write that out
by hand unless you have a printer
attached to your computer
and give it to me over the lunch hour or
before you leave which i hope will be
mid afternoon at the latest
i want to have this hard copy so i can
take it back to my office and work late
tonight
i have some
something i have to attend to tomorrow
so i will not have a lot of time to do
it tomorrow yeah just a reminder and
thank you to representatives leon and
shapiro that they have decreed and i
agree that march 21 to 25 is a vacation
week for this committee i'm not
responsible for anybody else
but that is vacation from us so if we're
going to get crossover bills um
[Music]
open the hearing on
oh no i'm not opening the executive
session
i'll learn it by the time we're done
house bill 1290 establishing a task
force on precision medicine and
biomarker testing
representative rogers work product thank
you so much and the chair calls on
representative soloway
back from the dentist
thank you mr chairman thank you
everybody thank you representative
rogers for bringing this before the
committee
1290 is a bill which establishes a task
force on precision medicine and
biomarker
testing that includes genetic screening
i would like to point out to you ladies
and gentlemen that we have been
presented
with two dreams one of which has ended
and that is the dream
that representative cushing would still
be serving in our house at this time
that dream has ended
we have also been presented with a dream
by representative rogers
who brings to us the possibility that we
can facilitate
a program of precision medicine that
will extend the lives of those suffering
from a variety of diseases
and perhaps save many of those
many of those lives
it is our question of how we might best
implement
such a dream
if we choose to use the tool
of the house
that will be a slow process that bill
would have to come out of this committee
it would have to go to the floor it
would be late in the season to begin
work on such an important task
i will be making a motion to
put this bill into interim study and to
ask the chairman to remand it to
the oversight committee for health and
human services
for expeditious action i would trust the
chairman of the oversight committee to
act before the end of this month
to appoint a task force
to deal with the issues that are raised
by a request for
attention to precision medicine the
chairman has a vacation week coming up
march 21 to 5.
i believe mr chairman if you check your
calendar there may be an oversight
committee meeting scheduled for that
friday i will not speak further to this
that is correct
um i would point out to you ladies and
gentlemen that these two dreams are in
fact one
and i am asking that the chairman
find a man
of a woman of wisdom
understanding and knowledge
to chair such a task force of the
oversight committee and to act
expeditiously
to produce a final report for the
consideration of a house and senate
i would add a point it's a personal
point
representative rogers is living through
this dream
uh it's a difficult dream to implement
and for her personally
it is an expensive dream there is a
gofundme site that has been established
in her name if you feel so inclined i
would respectfully request that you
access the gofundme site
and that you give generously and
philanthropically to the gofundme site
with that mr chairman
i would like to move
the interim study on this bill
do we have a second representative gay
seconds this
anything
that we may wish to ask of
representative soloway or representative
rogers who's here with us or wish to say
because in an exact session it does not
the chair only asks that the honorable
gentleman would assist me in the pulling
together this task force
since we both serve on oversight
i do have a list it so happens uh ready
to go mr chairman thank you for the
request over drinks we'll talk about it
who's buying i believe it's my turn this
time
seeing no
the motion before us is interim study on
house bill 1290
moved by representative soloway seconded
by representative gay with the
clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus representative
weber
representative mckay
representative snow absent
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon
yes representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative goods yes representative
merchant yes representative pearson yes
20 to 0 passes
and before you leave today
representative soloway
thank you
this concludes the exact session on
chair opens
the exec session on house bill
1379 we have a couple of amendments
and
[Music]
i just need to know if everybody's got
both amendments one is
943 which was dated march 3rd
the other that i have is 844 dated
february 24th representative cofoult is
leaving to get
one of those amendments i think
okay maybe he's leaving to get both of
them
actually he's not
he's leaving to get one of them and he's
okay
now the question is where's the bill
um
once you have both amendments please
take a few minutes to read it and then i
will call on representative cofoul to
you
representative kofalt would you speak to
both of your amendments please
thank you mr chairman um so you will
notice that my name is on both
amendments um
representative merchant has informed me
that um he was notified my name ols
could not take my name off of
amendment 844h
and i believe uh representative gay also
um
wants to take her would would have would
have liked to take her name off of it um
so
representatives woods merchant gay and
myself got together and i want to first
say i i deeply appreciate the
um
the efforts they brought to
to come up with a bipartisan amendment
that would make everybody happy
the the
the longer of these two amendments is
the first version of what that committee
or that working group produced
um
and um
essentially what this does is it
takes the three vaccines that are
currently mandated in rules
it
takes one of them varicella and puts it
in statute permanently
it takes the other two and puts them in
statute with an expiration date of june
30th of 2026.
if i'm
[Music]
yeah june 30th 2026
um
the idea being that the the legislature
ought to be the body that determines
these things it ought not to be left to
administrative rules given the
um the gravity of the decision to
subsequent to coming up with this first
version
i had a conversation with a number of
other colleagues who expressed some
serious concerns about a few things that
were in that version namely that it
moves varicella into statute
and if the premise is that
these decisions ought to be
given the full light of day through the
legislative process
we ought not to be adding it uh without
giving notice and without having that
debate in a publicly noticed hearing in
advance so the varicella really deserves
the same level of attention that the
other two do
the the other provision in the longer
amendment
is that
if if there were a situation in which a
vaccine needed to be mandate and there
were concern as to the
timeliness with which the legislature
could act
the longer version of this amendment
makes a provision for for a kind of
temporary mandate
and the temporary mandate would be for
20 months
and it would be
um the the dhhs commissioner would
establish that mandate but it would
require a three-fifths vote by the
legislative oversight committee the hhs
legislative oversight committee
the idea of being there that there would
be some legislative involvement in that
process
and being a supermajority of that
committee
that it would be a relatively high bar
to to meet
some concerns that i've heard since then
is that there isn't necessarily a public
hearing process for that
that it sets a precedent for that
committee performing a function that
it has not
ever
performed in the past
that it also may create some confusion
that the the
the shorter version of these two is is
succinct and and
relatively clearer
um and
that the temporary mandate mandate may
not in fact be necessary because
um in fact we
we see relatively high
compliance voluntary compliance with
mandates and particularly if there were
that
uh urgent a need that a mandate would
not necessarily be
the way to go
so
with that um you know i'll say that the
shorter version uh
quite simply says
what the original bill said which is
that rulemaking authority for the
commissioner with respect to childhood
vaccinations would be revoked but it
clarifies that in order to not have a
break with current practices
the the existing rules with respect to
haemophilus
hepatitis b and varicella would remain
into effect in effect until they expire
in 2026 which would give the legislature
four years in which to
go through that
full and transparent process of
where did the date of june 30th 2026
come from for the
um
rules vaccines is that something that
came from
you does it exist presently no that
comes from
the the particular rules in question um
because they expire after 10 years the
starting date is in 2026 so in essence
we're saying that they would continue
thank you mr chairman
and
would you believe that in fact
the oversight committee has had several
committees over the last
few years that have been very successful
and expedient moved very quickly
so that whoever was telling you that was
ill-informed it's been well established
point me to where additional
immunizations
may be put
in place
who does it and show me where that is
listed um under the under the shorter
amendment it would the the
the ability to add additional
mandated vaccines for for children would
sit would rest with the legislative
process how do i know that
i trust you but
somebody says to me point it
well i i would assert that the fact that
the legislature has done it in the past
and that this section
specifically
mandates diphtheria mumps pertussis
polio rubella rubiola and tetanus is
is evidence of of the fact that
precedent exists the the legislature has
put those in the statute and established
those as mandated vaccines for for
children
so this is one of those in the hierarchy
of
who says who
it is precedent
it's not here anywhere
in
writing i'm trying to clarify what i
think i heard you say correct i mean i i
it's essentially saying i mean i i think
there is precedent here um in statute
that the legislature has in the past
created
vaccine mandates for children
and so so that
that would not change
okay
mr chair okay representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um i i think it's
just
kind of um
inherent
that in law what's
the body that changes laws is the
legislature and that's
that's from the state constitution
okay
representative merchant
my preference is one over the other but
i don't have a pr
i can support either one of these the
difference really comes down to is
whether we want to provide
any kind of a
safety valve for the department of
health human services to be able to
introduce
a vaccine through a statute but
recognizing the fact that the
legislative body doesn't move that fast
and sometimes maybe a need for it the
safety valve was for the department of
health human services to get the
approval from the oversight committee
either one still protects
the current vaccines we have
three of them as representative cobalt
said are in rules it moves them now into
statute they remain there for two
legislative cycles which is four years
it gives us ample amount of time
to have a debate with the legislative
body about
what we want to do with those three
vaccines
i prefer to have the ability for the
department health human services to
have the ability to have a safety valve
but i can live with the other amendment
that representative cole faults put
forward
thank you
my concern
is
that we seem to be acting like we can't
give
a recommendation to the public for a new
vaccine
that to me is not implied in this bill
and this amendment
i don't think i think the issue here is
whether it's a mandate or not
whether the recommend whether the
commissioner can
mandate
a new vaccine i don't think there's any
any problem that it's not at stake here
whether the commissioner can recommend
a new vaccine to deal with a new issue a
new disease
so to me it's a non-issue
whether the
whether the authority is given to the
commissioner
to me the commissioner can always
recommend
something to deal with a new situation
representative leon
thank you mr chairman
i think we saw a bill this year
1633 that spoke to mandating the coveted
vaccination after full fda approval so
if there's something coming down the
pipe that is in the regulatory process
the legislature will have time to
consider it and consider that process as
it is working through development and
working through both clinical and
real-world experience so i think that in
a novel disease state
the legislature would be well aware of
any disease in the development of a
vaccine
i think the ones that we know about we
know about and
if there's an outbreak of something
there's the recommendations and we saw
greater compliance with recommendations
than mandates and so i i like this that
it gives those two sessions for those
three vaccines that are in rules
and just sort of walks quietly and
allows for those recommendations as
representative gay said and makes
mandates come through the house and
senate and governor
representative cofolt
i i also just want to reiterate that
voluntary uh voluntary vaccination rates
are are actually quite high um
the the
the vaccination rate for
um
for hpv for example is is around 70
as i understand it so
it's not necessarily
um
a a vaccine mandate isn't necessarily
getting us from zero to a hundred or
zero to eighty or ninety um it is
quite likely the difference between 70
and 80 or 70 and 90.
and
so i i guess my my concern
about putting varicella into this in
particular because i have heard from a
number of people who have serious
concerns about that
is that i think we owe it the the
the whole principle of this bill the
whole reason it was brought forward is
because there ought to be
a full and transparent process through
the legislative process on these on
these decisions
that that ought to
that ought to rest with the legislature
and that we really owe it to the people
we represent to
to go through that process for them and
so that that's why you know i feel
fairly strongly that the the varicella
requirement in particular
um ought to uh to go back into
the same category as the other two which
is let's let's retain those through june
of 2026
and
someone can put forward a bill
between now and then
where and we can go through that process
the chair um has a question
given how long it takes for the
legislature
to run through the hoops
my question is to representatives mckay
and weber
i'm relatively new as chairman of
oversight in your experience and
knowledge has oversight ever held a
public hearing prior to its doing
anything in your
remembrance
i will state that i don't remember it
having done so but i know of no reason
why it couldn't we have in the course of
our meetings often particularly when
they are in person taken comment
when appropriate from other people
but i i think that we are possibly
making this
matter where we have a very small
distinction between two very similar
bills
i i'm wondering if we're overthinking it
and if it would not be a good idea to
take a vote
i will be glad to be corrected by by
representative mckay whose
service on health and human services is
my memory is that
that certain issues were brought before
the oversight committee
and
it had been
thought through
in
either in committee or elsewhere
that the fastest way to get to this
particular issue
was to go to the oversight committee
it had to be
a member of the oversight committee
that had to take some responsibility for
starting that committee work
but that my memory is that that worked
extremely well
and in fact it was brought in
to deal with things like this
with a very knowledgeable
membership
so that
yes i think there have been
issues brought before the oversight
committee
a committee was formed the committee
came back and reported to the oversight
committee
but the chair is correct i've been
around for
about 22 years i think so each
house member of oversight is a present
or former member
of at least
one term
in this committee
and senator rosenwald who is one of the
three senators is also a veteran of this
committee
so
the oversight committee is not random it
is people who deal and have dealt with
health
and human services
issues
my concern is if
there is something that we cannot
foresee
that would need legislative action not
that i want more work
but oversight committee is fast
um
it meets all but the summer months it
will meet september october november
december this year
the legislature will not so if that is
naming oversight as opposed to
just assuming the legislative process uh
would be for your consideration
representative knurk
i still have some concerns about the
either one of these amendments but the
uh amendment
943 more so tying the hands of our
public health experts in the event of
some need for a nimble response
and i was wondering since we're talking
all about something that affects them
could we perhaps ask them to weigh in on
the two amendments and see if they have
anything important to say that might
guide our decision making
let's look out and see if we have
anybody from health and human services
here this morning
i'm thinking abby rogers would be a
and not only abby
good morning chairman pearson members of
the committee i'm abby rogers
legislative liaison for the division of
public health services and anna mccurry
just introduced yourself thank you for
allowing us to speak uh on this bill as
i can remind the committee the
department has significant concerns
about the underlying bill and testified
in opposition
the commissioner's ability to
require vaccinations uh is extremely
important to protect public health and
we we strive uh
to balance individual choice
taking that into consideration but but
this is to protect public health
and that's a consideration i know that
you're all aware of that but we are
concerned that these two amendments
would limit the ability to protect uh
individuals in case of an outbreak that
would need to be immunized quickly and
effectively to control the spread of
communicable disease i know there's been
a lot of discussion in this committee
and in other committees in the
legislature about concerns around the
coven 19 vaccine specifically and we
have said multiple times that the
department has known no indication in
requiring that vaccine and this
committee yesterday i tell the bill that
would have required that so just that as
a reminder
we
work very closely with the health and
human services oversight committee and i
agree with everything that's been said
about that committee moving very quickly
i think that the concerns that we have
is certainly those that have been raised
here about the ability of the
legislature to meet quickly to determine
whether a requirement
should be put forward
we believe that the the rule making
authority as exists requires legislative
oversight through jail car to approve
vaccinations these recommendations are
made regulatory on the federal level
through asip
and we feel that um the process as is in
place now is sufficient to protect
public health we would be very concerned
about changing that we do understand
that there are concerns about additional
oversight and we hear those concerns um
the idea of either having a recommended
vaccine by the commissioner looked at
thoroughly by the health and human
oversight committee would be something
that would be
acceptable certainly
and also i know that the just to mention
that i know the committee yesterday
through
hb 1045 reconstituted the ethics
oversight committee which has a lot of
responsibilities in the area of vaccines
per hb 187 which this committee passed
last session so those would be
the comments that i would make on on
these amendments specifically and the
issue before you turn it over um
i wrote this down quickly i hope i wrote
it down accurately that while i trust
and have great respect for the current
commissioner i don't know if i met her
successor
so
that's a different thing
i believe you said
that you would like the ability for the
commissioner to move quickly to immunize
did you mean recommend immunization or
you all got to line up right now
oh no of course i'm sorry if i if i said
i was confused on that obviously the
recommendation for immunize of a
requirement uh not
certainly forced immediately very
important clarification thank you for
that thank you to
just to get us back to what the bill
does this is just talking about
children's immunizations for school it's
not talking about the response
to a pandemic is that correct
that is correct that is correct unless
the pandemic involves school children
and my next question if i may you may
is
in the event that there was a pen
having just lived through a pandemic
that was
more severe than anything i've seen in
my 69 years
would it be possible
in the event of a desperate emergency
and the right vaccine being miraculously
available in time
for the governor to issue an emergency
order
and that's correct
thank you
so i'm going to argue to the committee i
don't know why we are splitting hairs
into four pieces over these two
amendments
i would certainly prefer
the
first amendment myself
but if we pass the first amendment i can
promise you that there will be a debate
on the floor as to whether the
legislature ought to be
referring its power to a committee that
is
very small
because we always have that debate when
we refer things to the fiscal committee
i also know we will also have a debate
on the floor about the varicella issue
so
i'm just saying to people that
distinctions are relatively small
and
i'm talking myself almost all the way
around to an itl motion
myself to an itl vote myself
but
that's
for debate and i'm sure we will debate
it
um i i could live with either of these
two but i'm beginning to think that itl
is the better
is the better response
if i understand the representative who
just spoke
we are not bereft
in a case of an emergency should itl
pass
we have the governor who can make
a um
i'm blanking the term edict no that's
not it emergency order that'll do that's
much nicer thank you we also have uh we
we trust
the ethics advisory committee we also
have the dhhs oversight committee we're
not bereft
of input should this bill be itled we're
not out there empty
exactly thank you chairman pearson i
think both of those
those committees would be a great place
to seek guidance and advice on any
future recommendations from the
commissioner
and i don't expect either of those
community committees ever to make a
mistake but in the unlikely event they
did
we can always have the legislature weigh
in because we
have the precedent for them to do so
that's correct
representative knurk i would like to
move itl
on hb 1379 please
pursuant to the conversation that
representative weber just made i'm going
to ask you to hold on to that for a
want to move forward with her at this
moment okay i want to hear a few more
people
seems like we ought to have a chance to
move
we could do that and if it doesn't pass
we can move something else
so it's kind of moot yesterday if i
recall we took an itl before we heard an
amendment so that is there is a
representative cofold i i would like to
move
amendment
ought to pass all right the chair will
accept that i think it's going to wind
up coming out the way
anyway i will accept that and the
amendment is 943h
correct and that is moved by cofault and
seconded by
cushman any further discussion
i do not see any hands for further
discussion
so um the motion that is on the floor is
amendments
2022-0943 h2 house bill 1379 moved by
representative kohful seconded by
representative cushman
and the uh clerk please call the role
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
yes representative kofalt yes
representative delemus
representative weber no
representative mckay no
representative snow
representative knerk
no
representative soloway no representative
cannon no representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant no
representative pearson gosh it's 10 10
until now isn't it
the amendment does not carry by a vote
of
10 to 11.
the chair will entertain a further
motion
make a motion to
past amendment
two zero two two zero eight four four h
uh and eight
four four amendments
is moved by representative
merchant
representative cannon
and the chair recognizes
representative webbing to start that
i i'm i'm going to vote against the
amendment although i think it is the
better of the two amendments and i don't
think it is that harmful but i think
that an itl motion is my preferred route
so
i'm just working out my tactics here um
i i i will vote
for the amendment and then i intend to
vote ita
against the ought to pass as amended
just
to get myself oriented as to where i'm
going i'm sorry
it's a strange room we're getting
acclimated representative leon
thank you mr chairman
i i really think that varicella deserves
its hearings and for that reason i know
that i'll be voting against this
amendment
but i think that that's an issue for
everybody to decide
sure
always
anyone else
the force is
as moved by representative merchant and
seconded by representative cannon
when the clerk is ready please call the
roll
representative leon
no representative mcmahon
representative acton representative gay
representative cushman
yes
representative folsom no representative
kelsey
representative cofoult
representative delemus yes
representative weber
yes representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk
representative soloway representative
cannon representative nutter alpha yes
representative shapiro
representative woods
representative merchant yes
yes okay
the gavel has not come down so you may
16-5 16-5
the motion carries
now the chair will entertain a further
motion
imove ought to pass on
as amended by
amendment
zero eight four four
move by representative cofoul seconded
by
somebody
the motion before us
is ought to pass
house bill 1379 is amended by
amendment
0844 moved by representative cofoult
seconded by representative gay
the clerk please call the rule
no
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
can i change my notes at the end of the
voting
representative gay
representative cushman
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king
yes representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk
representative soloway no
representative cannon no
representative nutter uppam no
representative shapiro no
representative woods
representative merchant
no
okay could i change mine to no please
you may change your menu order for lunch
at the same time don't get upset with me
if i don't get the count right first
time around okay oh snow is moving i'm
going to ask the clerk
to
call the role to make sure that we've
got it correct
or that it has been done correctly
okay
is she ready
you don't have to resp well
she's going representative leia she's
going to call the name with how you
voted okay
and
you only say anything
okay representative leon
yes yes representative mcmahon yes
representative acton yes representative
gay yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
cofoult yes representative delemus yes
representative webber no representative
mckay yes representative snow
no representative knurk no
representative soloway no representative
cannon no representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant no and
representative pearson yes
everybody happy
and the motion carries
and that means representative cofoult by
the end of the lunch hour
um
no no minority report um does it go to
consent though no okay oh no
okay thank you all right no minority
this ends the
exec session on
house bill 1379
all right
um are we ready with 1439 hospital
visitation policies where amendments
open the exact session on house bill
and they're coming
around
you have a 1439
amendment
[Music]
understand that's why baton first isn't
always the best thing exactly
although that allows for a
reconsideration yes it does it can be it
can be but my daughter gave me a copy of
me
[Laughter]
and since i'm buying solo is drinking
bourbon when he's buying up her drink
and i just hold my nose and throw it
back
the hey
all right we should have before us
amendments 952 unless the prime sponsor
is pulling it
i i'd like to first consider 10 12. we
will con but if we're
do we wish to consider 952 at all
because we would like to take a look at
it
or
there's
there's 953 which was the one we spoke
to yesterday
yeah i am reading is that a two that's a
three
oh my goodness i am reading the number
oh 9 52 it doesn't have written
yes 952 doesn't 952 just didn't have the
word written that one was not supposed
to be distributed it was 9.53
all right i don't have that one and i am
apologizing to ols for all of my
multiple amendments
is there a stray copy of 953 anywhere
may i have a straight copy
the only the only i don't want your copy
i just wonder if there's an extra one
the only difference is the word written
different
three fifty three and fifty two the only
it will be a new thing for us but yes
it appears to me that there are two
previous leon amendments 952 and 953 and
perhaps if she were to state that she
doesn't want to offer either of them
we can then progress
to
the amendment that she actually does
want to
discuss well then i guess
at this time i don't want to offer
either of those right now i'm looking to
offer 10 12. well let's take a look at
1012 shall we
so um 1012 builds upon our
long and involved discussion yesterday
um on line 17 through 22 lines 17 and 18
add in back in the presence of visitors
would be medically or therapeutically
contraindicated in the best clinical
judgment of healthcare professionals
given that this is in the licensing
statutes
because and because this is the area
that's the most likely to have some
contention and disagreement it states
that the reason for denial of a visitor
or medical for a medical or therapeutic
contraindication shall be documented in
the patient's medical record there's
already a lot of documentation that goes
on so if you're coding a patient they
they were coded and we asked the visitor
to leave should suffice if the patient
or their representative which may be
their
who they have through their power of
attorney or somebody else they designate
wants to know the reason they have
access to that reason for denial
this simply protects both the patient
and patients rights to have their
visitor and it protects the hospital as
well because if they've documented that
joe
kept getting in the way when they were
trying to put in the central line that
is a great reason to kick joe out of the
room
and that if they ever try and argue that
that
um the presence of yes it says
number one the reason for deniable
visitor or medical therapeutic
contraindication should be documented in
the patient's medical record whenever
there's one of these clear things
especially with dictating into into the
voice
medical records it seemed to be the
least burdensome way to protect
everybody's rights so this this does
keep it in licensing statute but that
provides more clarity around what might
representative weber
thank you and i appreciate that
we have
moved half the remaining distance to the
goal line but i don't think we're there
with this amendment first of all
it continues
the presence of all of this language in
the licensing statute which i opposed
i i get the point about documentation
but we are talking about what happens
when somebody's already in the grip of a
pandemic and hospitals are at the ends
of their
uh ropes in terms of staff and resources
and this is making things even more
difficult for them
because
the
uh we're putting a line into the
patient's bill of rights which
incorporates a right by reference that
nobody knows how to look up in a time of
stress
and we're also making the patient's bill
of rights which started out as a very
simple document
a much more complicated and legalistic
one and and i don't think that's a great
my
preference would be to itl this bill
entirely but i can live with the weber
amendment which is 0.946h
speaking only for myself i cannot
support
the new any of the layout amendments but
this one's better than the last but i
can't support it thank you
representative leon um thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
weber for that i think that when we're
defining these rights either we're
looking to add 50
50 something new lines to the patient
bill of rights with your offering or one
that that references in mine
neither of them are simple or elegant
solutions but we found that visitation
has been a problem and
it's not only a pandemic issue there
also may be issues in the future so this
is not related just to a pandemic
and thank you for your insight i i
believe that the licensing is the
correct place because um there aren't
there's there's not really any
repercussions for denying this access
to patients and we've been told that
it's not happening
if patients are not being denied
visitors
then it's not a risk for the licenses of
these facilities um so that's why i
believe it's the right place to be thank
you
further discussion
representative kanark uh mine's just a
simple question i think it's simple on
your original amendment um oops now i
just grabbed the wrong one oh wait a
minute
we were asked to make it simple so we'll
try on the original here we are
when the original amendment didn't we
still have in the phrase that was
present
below what is now on line 17 number a
the the line was there the presence of
visitors would interfere with the right
with the care of or rights of any
patient
um
here it was it was on your original one
online would you give the number to that
sorry the original one nine five three
fifty three seventeen
the presence of visitors would interfere
with the rights or care rights of any
patient that is now absent on the new
one and i was curious why that was left
out
no
actually that thank you it's there's
still only three i missed i missed that
and editing it because they came in
eight minutes before we started this
executive session right um if we can
recess this hearing i'll get them to add
be back in we have a couple more bills
still i apologize
yeah it's not b that needs to go in it's
the it's what used to be your number a
and the first in your first amendment
which would now become yes probably b
and and and in the original bill it was
b yeah because the a yeah the original
was b
thank you yeah exactly yeah but i was
referring just to your previous
amendment
okay while we're up representative snow
would like to add something to this in
yeah it needs to come after
representative
if the patient is incapacitated but not
the representation yeah i mean we don't
like incapacitated representatives
we can make some suggestions we're
outside of the um exec session but we
can make some suggestions to the
representative
uh who is going to uh wordsmith
this and
watch it waft to the fourth floor or
and because i tend to forget these
things
the sign ups for the original bill
and representative shapiro i think is
the one who usually likes to know this
is 109 signed in for
four people signed in against so there
it is
now what do we have here
oh
um
chairman opens the exec session on house
bill 1035
relative to exemptions from school
vaccine mandates and we have got a
plethora
of
amendments or at least we had
i have one that's been
given to me dated
uh february 25th the amendment is 8 54.
you shouldn't have it because i have a
big stack of them and you're about to
this is 10 35.
and we've got all kinds of amendments to
and representative cushman do you wish
to have yours 7 10
looked at or waved off waved off all
right
simplify
7 10 the whole batch of seven tens goes
up
you're about
to get 854.
the only the only one right now
everything else eventually has i mean
has been not eventually everything else
has been withdrawn
i trust you've read it by now all eight
lines
who would wish to
it is in the name of representative lang
who is from another committee who is
going to introduce it to us
representative leon
thank you mr chairman
this bill this is sorry this amendment
just seeks to remove the requirement for
notarization for the
religious belief exemption for school
i don't know about you but i constantly
hear on my town facebook pages how do i
get a notary how do i get a notary my
bank isn't in town where do i go
um it
for things where you're removing
yourself from a registry i understand
the need for a notarization but in order
to
share that you have deeply held
religious beliefs that the notary does
not inquire about it seems to be too
much of a burden for our parents who are
trying to get their kids to school to
after school activities making sure
their lunch is packed making sure they
have their jackets that
this requirement for a notarization
just adds one more step yeah i'm okay
with that okay so i'm hopeful that we
can all support this
and um this becomes the bill this
representative weber
well just state that your town or city
clerk is always a notary which is a
great place to go
but i also agree
this is not a
situation in which we are worried about
somebody impersonating somebody else
and the schools would be in a good
position to figure it out if they were
so i don't have any objection
to removing the notarization line
representative canark i generally feel
the same as represented weber but i'd
actually like to appeal to her knowledge
base what about if they have an issue of
custody issues and one parent and the
other parent disagree is there would
this help at all or not representative
weber a notary is not going to have
knowledge of that and the schools are
likely to have knowledge of that and
they are likely to have
fierce policies on how to deal with
those situations because they've been
dealing with them for a very long time
and in in those cases maybe somebody's
going to wind up in court if you have
parents battling over these things but
that is well beyond the scope of this
and the schools are set up to deal in
one way or another with
parents who disagree and
i'll make a motion to pass the amendment
okie dokie and that is representative
merchant as seconded by a republican you
qualify lay on
any further discussion i mean i haven't
i haven't looked at your
government-issued republican member form
the amen the
motion before us is
amendment zero 0854
to house bill 1035 as moved by
representative merchant and seconded by
representative leon would the clerk
i hope so
which amendment is it now just to make
sure the amendment is eight five four
ready
okay
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman no
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knerk
representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham no
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
18 to 3 the motion carries the motion
carries 18 to 3 the chair now calls on
himself to make a motion i move
house bill
that is my motion a second from this
side representative merchant thank you
with the clerk please call the roll
do you need to make your title
you have to introduce it
make your speech the clerk is calling
the rule on house bill 1035 is amended
by
amendment zero eight five four is moved
by the chair and seconded by
representative merchant
thank you
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk
representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham no
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes
representative pearson yes
objection no objection to consent thank
you and sometimes i talk to myself and
this will be a good time get that
i was sparing others of who are writing
many reports today from having to do
another one
all right now what do we got now what do
we have
i think we still have 14.95
yes we do we do
okay
this closes the exact session on 10
and now
the chair opens the exact session on
1495.
relative to vaccine mandates for
government contractors there is a
an amendment
and this is we have one but you would
like the new one yes i would like us to
i would like us to consider 10 13.
okay so nine five nine five two goes
away
is that your wish you're not presenting
952 no i'm not presenting 952. okay not
presented
good
ever think of having a career as a
professional amendment writer
no because then i'd have to proofread
uh
representative leon would you introduce
your amendment 1013 please
thank you mr chairman um taking into
account um the great conversation we had
yesterday
i have added language so that the state
agencies whose job it is to certify
medical facilities or providers for
medicare or medicaid are allowed to do
that certification
this simply allows them to do the job
which we have allowed them to take on
for the federal government so that it
does not jeopardize the reimbursement
for medicare or medicaid
otherwise it leaves the prohibitions on
requirements
in place
i thank the representative for adding
that in which i think is a great step
forward um i i will therefore vote for
the amendment but for all the reasons we
discussed yesterday i'm going to vote
against the ought to passes amendment
but i really appreciate the work that's
been done
to at a minimum assist the hospitals and
the counties and the nursing homes
so you're in favor of the amendment
but the amendment becomes the bill
i am in favor of the amendment because i
think it's better than anything i've
seen so far i appreciate your clarity
against the underlying bill and i am
against the underlying bill as amended
because i don't think
that
we fully know
what the ramifications might be for
other industries which we on the health
and human services committee are less
my
i i will be voting no on or not to pass
as amended but i think the amendment
certainly
goes a long way to solving at least
some of the issues involved in the bill
thank you for your clarification anyone
else
you're on your own today there you go
[Laughter]
anyway
i assume that this also does not prevent
any business or contractor from deciding
to require this on their own it's just
that they can't be required to do it is
that correct there's nothing about this
wording that says they can't do it
that's correct this is not this just
means that they can't require the
businesses to do it
it says nothing about what the
businesses are or are not able to do
this prevents us from being boston in
anyone else representative merchant
thank you
i also like represented weber have a
concern about the narrowness of
this being applicable to health care
facilities i think there may be other
additional agencies that have to comply
with both federal and
law or regulations that
could be
pulled into it
so i want to say thank you to the
representative for making the change i
think it's a step in the right direction
i just don't think it's far enough i'd
rather see it exempting state agencies
from all federal as well law or
regulations so we're not just talking
about health care
facilities representative folsom
um if we
uh pass this amendment and then the bill
is there not a chance in the senate for
them
to add any
amendments of other industries that
people might think of by then
representative weber
there absolutely is but
without wanting to cast any aspersions
at our friends on
the other side of the wall or in the
other building or downstairs wherever
they may be located
their process
of necessity because there are so few of
them
is a much more abbreviated
process than is ours so
um
unless people in those industries are
particularly vigilant
there i have a concern that that would
get taken care of um
and and again i i am this is speculation
on my part because i don't have the
expertise to know myself thank you
we would not wish
an omnibus bill with 700 parts coming
our way
in my opinion
anyone else representative gay
thank you
uh is there any way we could generalize
and say federal requirements
representative leon
that would cover those areas but that
opens the door much broader than this is
trying to do this is trying to say that
the state won't require businesses to do
these things if they're required by the
federal government to do that
we
that's a relationship between the
federal government and the business
the question here is what other state
regulatory agencies are charged by the
federal government and accepted by this
state to be the enforcement arm of the
federal government can we say it that
way
so instead of specifying
which agencies we would be affected by
is there any way to make it more general
term so we don't have to worry about
some other
entity coming up and saying but but in
order to pass we have to
do it too this bill narrows but it
doesn't exclude in other words it's not
mentioning one way or the other anyone
else it's mentioning these people these
these groups which came out of our
hearing another bill at another time
perhaps could expand the focus but we've
got a tight bill on specific things here
with the amendment as as the presenter
attempts to do
i'd like to keep this clean we're
seeing uh no further um discussion or
hearing none
uh we are looking at the motion the
motion would you like to do what i'm
trying to say thank you mr chairman i
would love to make a motion thank you i
thought you would because
i move that the committee adopt
to house bill
1495. anyone over here interested get on
it not if not um
the motion before us is amendment
2022-1013
on house bill 1495.
motion is ought to pass moved by
representative leon and lay on and
seconded by representative kelsey would
the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom
yes representative
i have to i have to do it at least once
a week you know just just to let you
know i'm still here you know i haven't
been transplanted somewhere
um representative kelsey yes
representative king yes representative
co-fault yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham no
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes
representative pearson
yes the amendment
passes twenty to one
the chair recognizes representative
if you're swamped with uh blurb writing
although you do a great job from the 40
i've seen recently uh you can pass it on
to somebody else or you can take it on
i know several of you are flashing me
the do not look at me please signs
representative acton our hero to the
front thank you sir the pride of
rockingham county all right
representative acton moves
and who is going to
second i will
and you are
full
full represent yeah folsom yeah all
right something wholesome from
representative
folsom so
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended
ought to pass house bill 1495 is amended
by
amendment 1013 moved by representative
acton and seconded by representative
folsom
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative cofoult
yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk no representative
salloway
representative cannon
no representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods no representative merchant no
representative pearson yes
passes 11 to 10. the motion carries 11
to 10
do not leave this building
without
something for me
thank you
no no
no i was not actually
i was i was trying to bring up a
different point sorry
i'll give you guys a few minutes to
decide who's going to do the minority
report that's what i was going to say
but thank you for saying it so well oh
i was actually going to ask could we
take a five minute biological break and
that might give us time to during the
five-minute biological break
you may come to a
conclusion as to who's going to write
the blurb or you can even write it and
have competing blurbs and whoever wins
can be the one five-minute break this
ends the hearing on
151 colon 2 1 a or d or a special
license under 151 2e
shall do this
those are
hospitals
are
facilities that operate as an outpatient
rehab ambulatory surgery center hospice
emergency center urgent cares birthing
centers dialysis centers
so what we have just done when we passed
137 is we said it's okay to exempt these
groups
from that portion of the statute
but just before that we passed one zero
four four by a fourteen to seven vote in
which we said that was not okay
so it was not affecting nursing homes
130 part two section two of one three
four seven essentially does exactly what
one zero four four was doing
uh
representative cushman is shaking her
head no but i i
the reason i didn't bring it up first
thing this morning i was
i went bonkers last night i even called
john williams at night i then i
worked with him this morning and we've
tried to figure out what's going on and
i think unfortunately
is your is the error we allegedly have
made and uh
that we just disagree politically or did
we do something that we didn't invest
well first of all i think we all thought
we were voting on whether or not nursing
homes could be exempted i'm seeing some
nodding heads i know that's what i
thought i was voting on this is the
hazard we always have when amendments do
come in just before is that we read and
we go through them but we can make
errors and so since it has to do with
the same substance of 104 which we
defeated 14 to 7 it does not make a lot
of sense that we passed this
and so i wanted to bring it up we
if we have we can still disagree we
should at least make decisions based
upon a knowledge of the bill that is
accurate and that's my concern i don't
think we did chair's going to recognize
representative cushman and then we may
bring forth um the uh
lobbyist
procedurally you may
you
representative weber
you may thank you
uh thank you i so
if
my understanding is what we can do at
this point is a member who has voted in
are we
set a member who is in the majority may
move reconsideration and then everybody
votes on whether or not we wish to
reconsider our vote and if we wish to
reconsider our vote we then proceed to
the
main event but i think it would be very
helpful in deciding whether we want to
reconsider
to hear from the folks who might have
some clarity to give us thank you
thank you representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um thank you
representative kanark there is an error
you're right in that um
in line 21
um really to make it do what we want it
to do we would just have ols draft an
amendment um that strikes the parent
parenthetical a and d
because under
151 colon two
section paragraph or section roman
numeral one
that's where it houses
resident under e residential care
facilities whether or not they're
private homes other structures built or
adapted for purposes for providing
residential care which may or not
be for elderly suffering from illness
injury deformity infirmity or other
permanent or temporary physical or
mental disabilities so those are
um
that would include nursing homes
so it would really be all of these
facilities under 151 colon two rehabs
are under there too just in a different
letter
and and then but the clarifying language
of exactly who it applies to is in
on the ba on the page two of the
amendment
um
in roman numeral 2 on line 3.
so it's saying that those exceptions are
only for
nursing home skilled nursing facilities
intermediate care facilities or rehab
facilities
that that's where it's clarifies that
it's not for hospitals and other um
kind of facilities
so but you're right that those two
letters
that is an error
so um i would request that we can recess
this so i can run over and get a
amendment um give that a minute i'd like
to call on um
loose
actually well they're coming up can i
just respond to that comment that was
made though you may okay um yes i agree
that it does say that those two will not
apply
um
but i think you were saying just strike
the a and the d
i
i i otherwise even if
if you say under on under 1 151 colon 2
roman 1 that still includes all these
other places um
and you've still exempted them
i think
so i think it's still a problem but
there's there's a secondary problem
which i think we want to hear from the
people who are not in the room when we
execute this yesterday
so
sorry i misidentified you your los dos
amigos
for now anyway
um good morning mr chair members of the
committee
excuse my voice i'm bob dunn i'm the
director of public policy for the roman
catholic diocese of manchester and i'm
here today on behalf of new hampshire
catholic charities which operates
several
long-term care facilities
and with me is kate horgan who as you
probably know
is from the dupont group and represents
the new hampshire association of
counties
and
i can understand the the confusion
around this because um these sections
are specifically romans 6 a
which begins on line 10
and and what i'm going to talk about and
kate and i are going to talk about is
really lines 8 through
17 and then
um the the final part of the
of the um
you are speaking to the amendment
when you are citing lies okay uh yes
thank you 0996
thank you
and um
so this is something that um some of you
may remember from your days those of you
that have been on
had the chance to vote as members of
your delegations
on the just a reminder that we are on
the clock so please suggest the change
and the reason for it with brevity and
then
representative cushman will respond but
we've got to pick up the pace this is
this deals with the nursing home bed
moratorium
which has been in the statutes for many
years and
for a number of years was was taken up
sort of as part of each budget
and then a few years ago it was made
just a permanent part of the statute and
it really is an essential part of the
way that the nursing home funding is set
up
both in terms of from the perspective of
the individual nursing homes but also in
terms of the state medicaid budget and
the county property taxes because as all
of you know
um the while the state
has you know
the state's name is on the check for
nursing home funding it's largely the
counties that pay for that through their
property taxes
and so
i would
suggest
removing the references
um
to
i would take
point of order
are we not discussing
the issues that were raised by
representative kanark and not the
content of the bill but just the
technical issues in the rsas that are
cited and are are we on a motion to
reconsider we are not on emotion at this
point
it just seems inappropriate that now
we're opening further testimony from
lobbyists against the bill on a
irrelevant issue that doesn't have to do
with the
the problem that representative canark
was representative canark well i did
bring up that i was concerned and
although you did allude to it in your
testimony during the hearing we and by
the way i did not orchestrate this they
just showed up
the but the
there was the bill original bill did not
have this and these people were not
there to testify at the original hearing
which is why i felt that this was
actually a non-germane portion of this
amendment because it brought in a whole
new concept it has not been ruled as
such i would like to limit our
discussion to texas
yes okay the other may have significant
merit but not now
and i would suggest that if you see i
don't see what you're seeing but i know
you both entrust you both and if you're
correct and i just haven't seen it i
would suggest that um you talk to the
senate we're going to limit
this to what representative kinork
brought up
not that i disagree or agree with you
but not at this point i accept the
representative's point representative
canark
no i'm i i i wanted to hear from their
point of view anyway because they were
not present to speak before but i think
it should be very brief but uh we are
not we are visiting what you initially
brought up as a mistake well i also
there is a section not also no but there
is a secondary well there is a secondary
feature and that is that there the
question came up about light sorry about
the nursing homes and their policies
and you brought up that there was a
private nursing home
that opened in your place and it didn't
have any impact but i have since
understood that that nursing home is
really a retirement community
right and so the point is again there
were multiple things we were saying
yesterday that were not correct and
community ccrcs are not the same and i
thought that we ought to get a better
understanding when we voted
so this was also in the mix with me i we
were talking back there i said that i
said and also i was concerned about this
i
but i about the section two but i think
there's still concerns about the impact
upon the nursing homes i agree and i'm
rolling that out for this time unless
there is a motion to reconsider
that carries
to reconsider what we did yesterday
representative merchant
thank you mr chair
having voted on the prevailing side i'd
like to make a motion to reconsider
and what do you wish to reconsider
i wish to reconsider
the lines 21 and 20. now you reconsider
oh reconsider
the bills the author sorry the other
pass vote which was 12 to 9. and you
voted in the majority i remember that
you have standing on this
so the motion to reconsider what we did
yesterday
is moved by representative merchant and
i see no second
i'm not sure that a motion to reconsider
i'm not sure that it is out of an
abundance of caution might someone not
move that way just in case we don't need
it representative snow in case we need
it
i think you only need one person who
voted in the majority to reconsider but
i
and you are contacting the clerk for
ruling
yeah fair enough let's do it right i
mean if there is somebody who voted in
the majority who wishes to second it
i have not seen anyone if there is
someone you may put your hand up you
no you can't you can't no you did not
the question before us is whether it
needs to be seconded
if you're asking if somebody is asking
the clerk questions we ought to ask the
clerk whether people who were not here
can vote on the reconsideration i would
think they would but i don't know that
either
so but
once the motion is made the whole
committee votes it's not just the
prevailing people who vote that is
correct so my question is is there some
prohibition
for people who were not here yesterday
because i
as long as we're asking the clerk for
guidance we might as well find out that
one as well
it makes no sense to me that a single
person can move for reconsideration and
then it has to be seconded because it
might be just one person who changes
their mind then you take a vote and and
but i don't know the rule about
seconding and if the clerk has a
we may continue to discuss this before
we decide whether we're going to revoke
so it seems like the issue that
representative connect was raising is he
felt that nursing homes and rehabs
aren't included in the statutes listed
on lines 21 and 22 but they are
d
which is included on line 21
and
nursing homes are covered in e
so
that statute does govern nursing homes
and rehabs and we are just exempting
them
in from
line 23 and line 26 a and b
okay and that clarification
is in on page two
in section paragraph uh roman numeral
two on line three sub sub paragraphs
one a and one b don't apply to nursing
homes skilled nursing facilities rehabs
intermediate cares including rehab
hospitals and facilities offering
comprehensive rehab services
so these are the ones that operate on
the membership-based business models
they're they're in the right place
they're covered in that statute and it's
it makes it clear that it's only those
ones that are being exempted from those
rules representative cushman do you see
anything in the amendment we passed
yesterday
that takes away
the
no new license no increased capacity for
nursing homes in general did this
inadvertently wipe that off the books
not in it
not inadvertently that's what paragraph
one is gonna do it all it takes the
it takes away the moratorium on new new
nursing homes and new um new rehab
facilities
if they operate on a it exempts them
if
if they operate on a membership-based
business model let's say catholic
charities wants to build another nursing
home the moratorium is still in place
that's correct okay but it it the
moratorium is really
you know based on the the building of
new beds it it it it isn't so much
directed at the facilities that exist
it's it's trying to preserve the number
of beds that exist as of today so there
can be no carve out for a private pay
nursing home
unless
yes yes okay so
the existing kinds of nursing homes
still cannot build more of without
permission the only permission is given
to the private pay ones
that appears to be the case okay that is
what you would test and i wanted to make
sure you heard that too okay good
i have a pay let's make sure we
understand not a private institution but
private pay or membership what what yes
that's not
whether you agree or disagree we're all
agreed in what we did
okay
the reconsideration needs a second but
it doesn't need to be from the
prevailing side
every reconsideration needs a second but
it doesn't have to be from the pres
prevailing side
and representative weber seconds now we
have a motion before us to reconsider
it's called a do-over
yesterday
so we are now um
with this being considered an executive
session on a reconsideration of
yesterday's um passing of
47 is amended port of order i think we
have to take a vote on the
reconsideration oh i know that's where
i'm leading to i'm just giving you the
the motion before us is a motion of
reconsideration on
house bill 1347 is amended by uh
amendment 996 voted on yesterday this is
reconsideration vote
representative correct uh responses are
yes or no but there was beautiful music
okay representative leon no
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman no representative
folsom no representative kelsey no
representative king no representative
cofoult no representative delemus
representative weber
yes
you can you're here because the person
stood in for you
vote oh
he can vote okay
um so what's your vote i'm sorry
yes
uh representative snow yes
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant yes
representative pearson no the motion
fails
but thank you so much
it's always an order and just to say i
do believe that representative cushman
did clarify that well i think the way
you're saying that i'm not sure we even
have to get rid of the one a and one d
that may have been my misinterpretation
i'm thinking it was too broad so i think
that we don't have an error that we're
propagating i don't agree with the
policy but don't have an error
propagating
okay that ends the uh exact session on
reconsideration on house bill 1347
thank you everybody for doing it the way
you all did
sorry y'all you've got me saying that
representative if representative marsh
was here he would say yinz
pittsburgh
it's a contraction of you ones anyway i
digress
openly
opened the
executive session on house bill 11 80
this was originally representative
gould's bill and it is relative to state
recognition of biological sex and you
should have an amendment from
representative gay
i have a chairman's copy if somebody can
[Laughter]
and it was a big deal when we finally at
the school i worked at got one that ran
that's right and that's why i wanted to
make that point i guess i should
reiterate at that point
um
yes
i hate to interrupt the time that you're
spending writing on your various
but we are getting an amendment and uh
it is amendment nine five nine
from representative
gay on house bill 1180 so once everybody
has it and has read it you can explain
it
mine mine mine
mine mine
remember that movie
representative gay tell us what your
amendment seeks to do
i i will move it too
so i move uh amendment 0959h
to house bill 1180 i wish it to pass
and do we have a second
second by representative acton now
representative gay if you would speak to
your amendment
um i found house bill 1180
far too in
exclusive
and uh but out of concern for
for people's concerns about
women's sports being affected by
trans women who may have been treated
rather recently and still
were
of competitive male standards
and
out of that concern
i deleted two-thirds of the
so
it just says
that
nothing yes it just affects sports
so nothing i'll read it nothing in the
subdivision is intended to prohibit any
public entity from differentiating
between male and female sexes in
athletic competitions
certainly if we want to expand this we
could get more specific about ages
but i just kept it extremely simple
and of course in this paragraph male and
female sexes is biologically male and
female
so
both
both parts of the bill
were in two different places so that's
why it says it twice
thank you representative cannon
in making this change
how does it make this bill with that
change different than legislation that
was brought to the house last year
we're hoping this one goes through
that's not the no representative weber
and
committee researcher alert
we may need a ruling on this whether
with if the amendment passes the bill is
too similar to a bill
that was voted on last year
if you would thank you representative
weber
thank you for raising that issue and
then the other issue i have
and perhaps it was discussed earlier but
i'm trying to figure out what on earth
the motor vehicle laws have to do with
personally i did not write this bill
i was just horrified at the extent that
it went
so as i made the assumption
that the attorneys who wrote it are
assisted in writing it
knew that it was addressed in other
sections so i
if if that's a
thank you mission i apologize it it
it still
doesn't seem to me to serve any purpose
and
i don't think we ought to be in the
business of passing laws that serve no
purpose and are not related to what
we're talking about so
that's a concern in this it it certainly
is
uh remove some of the concerns on behalf
of the department of corrections and and
places of accommodation but i still
think it's a very very
if it was from last year on this
particular topic
yes
does anyone have a number it was on
banning
transgenders
in sports
it was in education
education
we're going to get a ruling as to
whether this actually be can can can be
considered
in an amended form because then it
becomes
close to
the question is too close representative
knurk
yes i
i really don't think we need this bill
whether we're discussing the amendment
we don't need the amendment because
because it becomes the bill
for the very simple reason that there
are
sports governing boards that have
existed for a very long time that govern
the all factors of competition
at the high school collegiate and
professional levels i did look and
they're like there are hundreds of
different boards and they all have
different policies
they struggle with this but they look at
the whole big picture they look at the
question of
um for example what uh you remember
there were people ski jumpers who got
disqualified for having the wrong too
much flap in their costumes
uh all kinds of factors that they take
into account in competition to make it
level and even
they have done this for a very long time
and many of them have already addressed
this
i don't think the state should be
sticking their nose into the process
of deciding how athletic competitions
are governed since we have groups that
already do that
representative folsom
um
and we'll find out for sure from the
researcher but it was my impression that
last year's bill was banning
transgenders in sports
of of their chosen um gender
this
purely allows
a
subgroup
whatever
that that
our team or school or whatever they are
now allowed by law
to
have rules regarding biological sex
within
their um organization this just
basically
um
uh
yeah it doesn't mean they have to ban
them it doesn't mean you know one sport
it might not make a difference another
sport it may
and this gives the organizations the
choice
representative shapiro yes thank you mr
chairman i think in our committee we
often ask ourselves is there a problem
that we're trying to actually fix
um and so i'm just wondering if anybody
in our committee
has
not really data but any
stories even anecdotal stories about
situations where
competition has become a problem in new
hampshire
i have a growing file since this bill
was introduced in education
maybe last year but definitely in the
previous term and probably both
i have a growing file on this very issue
of which state which school
which competition the file continues to
grow
i remember when i took point on this
bill the first time
we could only cite a few examples
now my file is very thick and growing so
i do not know whether this has occurred
yet in new hampshire but it's and i have
not gone through the file to see with a
list of states how many states now this
has been a problem my guess is it is
growing i guess it will happen here
someday
and we have addressed matters in
thank you mr chair
how does this address the issue of a
biological female taking testosterone to
enhance their body mass to be unfair
competition against those they're
i think
ncaa prohibits it i don't know what the
rules are
for high school
i think most of us have a gut feeling
thank you mr chair
the
new hampshire interscholastic athletic
association has a transgender policy in
place
that covers both male to female and
female to male
athletes
the ncaa
has transgender policies in place that
will actually goes a step further than
most policies in that it take blood
tests to assess
the testosterone level in both male and
and yet we are seeing again and again
and these are the only clippings i put
into my file
where
an individual
who in competing in an all-male team
was mediocre
but now competing in a female team
is winning and making state records
those are the clippings i keep
two weeks ago
a young lady
in pelham
on a wrestling team
a champion wrestler on a boys wrestling
team
it was announced in wmur will be going
to the state finals she has beaten all
of the boys in her weight class there
are two more wrestlers female wrestlers
on boys teams in their middle school
i appreciate that thank you so much
my my wonders i don't know how long it's
going to take to get a ruling and we may
be
arguing a moot point i'm told we are
anybody want to sing the
theme to jeopardy
i know
representative uh former speaker
shirtless ruled that one out and he was
i'm going to make an executive decision
and stop the um exact session on this
bill until we have an actual ruling we
may be expending emotion
unnecessarily so
let's go to something
totally non-controversial
and we're do we ready to go to nursing
homes
14th
yes that's what i mean you know what i
mean we are now going to open the
executive session on house bill
um
representative rice's bill initially and
we have another amendment for our
collection
this one's um
we can ignore 9.53
we can get rid of 9.53 okay and it's
been upgraded with inflation to 1019
and how about 10 12.
we can also dispose of 10 12. whatever
environmentally responsible way you
choose i do have a fire recycled this
paper
and the only amendment we're now looking
at is
we're short is there any more amendments
any extras on this side of the
playground
thank you over here
the only amendment we're considering
representative is 10
19. if you've got another amendment to
well she's pulling them all for
10 19. yes
right
so i'm just reminding you that we still
have the issue of 9 46. this chair
stands corrected 946 by representative
weber is still in play i beg your pardon
thank you for the correction and right
there on the piece of paper that tells
representative leon would you wish to
would you please speak to your amendment
which is 10 19.
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative knurk you will find that
what you were looking for on line 23 of
page 1.
the care and rights of other patients
are paramount and i greatly thank you
for finding that oversight in the
drafting
now that this has been corrected and
also says if the patient's incapacitated
and not their representative i thank you
for that representative snow
these are important changes we are
writing law here
we now
have added back in the presence of
visitors which we medically or
therapeutically contraindicated in the
best clinical judgment of healthcare
professionals with documenting that and
making it available
it stays within the licensing statutes
but that should provide
a good way to document when access to
visitors is denied for something other
than the written hospital policy
i would expect that disruptive
threatening or violent behavior towards
any staff member patient or any visitor
would be in the security logs so that
will also protect the hospital if
if jane is a little upset about her
husband's treatment and she starts
getting agitated the security will have
a note of that so the hospital won't
likely won't be at risk from jane coming
back and saying that she was a sweet
princess
as we look at all of this it provides
protections for the patient
having visitors
and now that we've strengthened this it
provides a lot better paper trail for
the hospitals as well to protect
themselves
if no hospitals are unduly denying
visitors today then this is not a threat
to the hospitals
and i believe that putting this in
licensing is the best way to go forward
to respect all stakeholders
so
thank you thank you any questions to
representative
leon
about
representative gay
thank you
uh
could you tell me which line that it
talks about the policy being in writing
um yes on line 26 of page one it says
visitors are non-compliant with written
hospital policy thank you
it also states which is appropriate
since this is
a requirement on the facilities
that
they
somewhere it says that they have to post
it
yes on page 2 lines 12 and 13 each
healthcare facility licensed pursuant to
one
rsa1512 shall post on its website
informational materials explaining the
rights specified in this section
so it provides for transparency it
provides for information it makes it so
that
if you actually look and see what's
going on you know what to expect and
that should diffuse a lot of these
emotional situations that are happening
because you know our first response our
medical professionals are doing so much
for us if we can just point to a clear
policy and make it not be personal make
it be written
i think it's going to go a long way to
well i'm going to say that the the weber
amendment also
satisfies all of those things it's
written it's not personal it's available
i think it's
far
clearer
in the weber amendment
because
the policy is set out
in writing
in the patient's bill of rights whereas
the patient's bill of rights that will
be posted under this one will just give
a statutory reference which doesn't help
a patient in crisis
i
appreciate the
adding back in of both a at online 17
and b on line 23
but i think that in the midst of a
medical crisis when resources are
stretched to their limits
asking for the health care professionals
who are trying to save people's lives
to have to do
extra additional documentation
of the visiting policies
is
i
may or may not vote for the amendment
i'm not sure it's certainly better than
what we started with but
i
think i will be voting itl on the whole
thing
and i would welcome hearing others ideas
about the amendment
the amendment meaning your amendment
the meaning any amendment the amendment
meaning the leon amendment because we've
discussed mine ad nauseam and that's
that's the one i would like but i
suspect that you're not going to i mean
if i
move mine i suspect you're not going to
take that motion i suspect you're going
to take this motion first and it's going
to be dispositive so
yep
representative anybody other wanting to
i'd like to hear from the hospital
association
as to do we have a paula minahan anyone
named paula minahan she's not here
anymore she's not here anymore
there's something
about having something on the wall
posted that makes it clear
as opposed to it being
equally true
but in
you have to go look up
we have printed policies in our facility
for a reason
and it's so immediately the professional
can point to it
and there is something of value to that
i think representative gay
is this there's nothing in here that i
see that would prohibit making the
policies
available and posted
the the most important thing instead of
telling they have to do it because it
could be extensive i do like the idea of
it being posted
but
but the most important aspect of this
bill is to make sure that it's where
if it's violated
there's a pain
because we have too many stories sad
stories about people being denied being
with their loved ones in the hospital so
we can't just put it in one place that
doesn't have teeth that's a convenience
that i really support posting it
that's a convenience for the people
who need to know they have rights
but it also is very important to make
sure
this
law this bill whatever you want to call
it gets followed and if there's no teeth
to it and it's inconvenient and we've
seen it
happen many times where the hospital
decided it was inconvenient so they just
said that's our policy you can't visit
and if it would seem let me pick up on
your point representative gay if it
seems
that it would have been helpful i think
that's future perfect
tense um
that these things were posted on the
wall they must be posted in every room
and they're not being posted
has led to some problems we can always
representative merchant thank you mr
chair
if you look at line 26
under the amendment this is the lay on
amendment correct thank you 10 19
h
videos visitors are non-compliant with
written hospital policy
the way i read that
all the things we're writing into this
statute to a certain degree
could be nullified by the written
hospital policy and i concur with the
fact that most patients don't have
access to a hospital policy what they do
have access to is their bill of rights
i think i really want to educate the
public and educate the patients and
educate their visitors
about what their rights are it should be
better in the posting on the bill of
rights
because that's where the patients are
going to look they're not going to look
for hospital policy and quite frankly
the hospital public policy can nullify a
lot of this
so i would say at this point in time the
logical place to put it is in a
patient's bill of rights so the patients
could in fact
see it
time and time again and know that they
have within the bill of rights what
their rights are not trying to penalize
the hospital but i think if you enforce
the patient and educate the patient that
in itself will bring a lot of bear to
the hospital itself
um
as far as the way i'm reading it
sorry it's been
it's dry in here um
it this does not
um
maybe i'm wrong but this does not stop
the hospital from putting some line in
the patient's bill of rights to clarify
this if they want to add it to
oh that's a statute okay thank you
while it doesn't prevent them from doing
so apparently they have not done it yet
so that's why we're here
representative um
weber
well i want to make it clear the the
patient's bill of rights is a statutory
thing and you can't put extra words in
or take extra words out
i suppose if somebody wanted to explain
what the visitation policy was
once they had posted
the patient's bill of rights they could
underneath that
post
the reference to this thing here but
that makes a very long and very unwieldy
process and i have
now recovered my wits from my last
thing about trying to figure out whether
i wanted to vote for this amendment
because it was better than the last one
or not welcome back i
well maybe
um i i truly think it should not be in
the licensing statute that was the
difficulty underlying difficulty
and i also
don't think that
rights of patients should be expressed
in
references to statute
so i will be voting no on the amendment
if that's the next thing that comes up
i would urge people to vote this
amendment down and so that we could
bring up the weber amendment
which
contains
the same thoughts
does not
overly burden hospital workers in an
emergency which is the only time when
people don't get to see their patients
their they're people in a hospital it's
either an emergency or a highly highly
infectious situation which would
fall under either a or b
so let's not put roadblocks in hospital
workers way when they're trying to deal
with a desperate situation
representative gay
thank you
i see no reason why we can't
ask put
amend this or this bill or somewhere
else to put it since you need statutory
approval to put something in
the rights
the patient bill of rights i have no
problem with it being in the patient
bill of rights somewhere on a big
letters that people see
but i have a big problem saying oh it
can't be in
um where this bill proposes to put it in
in a place that has teeth
because we've seen too many times for
the convenience of the administration
and lord knows who
the people were denied
these rights
and i think it has to be where it's
taken seriously but that shouldn't have
to exclude it from easy access by the
visitors and the patients
representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman um
first i would like to say that when i
was i when i was in private practice
there's a mental health bill of rights
and um
i had to have that on the wall and it it
was actually a source of conversation
starter about what we were actually
doing together and in the best of all
circumstances that's what the
bill writes for a medical patient would
be as well
an interactive
documented interactive process
so
i do support it being in the
i'm having a hard time with people
referring to
hospitals restricting visitation because
it's inconvenient for them
and i'm i'm certainly i don't know all
the details i don't know all the
situations
i have to believe that hospitals have
made mistakes at times in terms of the
restrictions that they've created
but i think it is really unfair of us to
sit in judgments of hospitals that were
dealing with um
unprecedented it's too you know we use
that word too often but unprecedented
situations and um i have to believe that
they were really trying to do the best
that they could and not only that but
in most cases did the best
and so i think
i would just suggest that people be
careful about
talking about medical providers who have
been under such duress
um
as
not caring really and just acting out of
their own convenience
as
a part-time ceo of a medical counseling
accuse us
of uncaring
and while i suggest our facility has
less than perfection
don't you ever accuse us
of being uncaring
and i understand
the frustrations my staff had to work
through
to provide as always the excellent care
now you also know i have another
part-time job
and i have people in hospital that i
would have liked to bring the sacrament
to and pray with
and i have never
throughout the two years of this
pandemic
heard a restriction placed on me
that i objected to
i didn't like it
i wished it were otherwise but i got it
and when i asked for
reasons
identifying who i was
i was satisfied with the reasons
so thank you representative shapiro i
and i'm i'm sorry to pile on but i need
to express my extreme concern about the
convent about
the fact that people were excluded for
the convenience of the administration
because i don't think hospitals or other
health care facilities ever do that
and
yes it was awful it was awful for the
people who were excluded it was awful
for the people who died alone
and i don't want that to happen to
anybody but to say that that was done
for the convenience of the
administration
in a time
of extreme duress
is just as far as i'm concerned
reprehensible so i'm just expressing my
objection to it and representative um
weber as i shared with you yesterday on
behalf of this committee i apologized
for that comment
to paula minihan and anyone
who runs a hospital and anybody who
listened to
this hearing yesterday and
and it was now made again today
anyone else
representative acton
i do i do want to convey a couple of um
realizations i had during this cove
situation
the if
at first i saw a coarsening of attitudes
and it was amongst my friends who were
our patient care providers
and um
i just the the daily
immersion in in this deadly situation
like a friend of mine works at the
elliott um
e.d
it just it tends to lead you to
to
coarse in your attitude simply because
you have to separate yourself
mentally from
from the trauma that's going around on
around you or else it could
um
drive you crazy
um but then i like for instance i went
down to the
booster blitz down in stratham
and the
the first responders and firemen are
running the thing
had had the line of people standing out
in
a torrential downpour in the beginning
of december it was raining like it was
a
mid-july storm and it was about 38
degrees
and they had no
no way to get out of the rain so there
was
average age 60 65 standing or getting
soaked and everyone's just standing
looking at the ground and the firemen
were all standing inside
looking out and knowing it never
occurred to anybody jesus we could swing
this line around over here and everybody
undercover
no and and so when i got up to the front
i asked the first person why are we all
standing out in the rain here was
totally soaked and she's like not my job
so i said well whose job is this mr
chairman i have an objection we have a
statute in front of us that's about
visiting rights in the hospital not
about lines in the rain in
covet vaccinations i think he's trying
to draw a parallel and i'm encouraging
him to draw it more quickly thank you
okay um
what i found was a continued level of
coarsening of attitudes which is
happens and that's happened in hospitals
as well
i'm not faulting it i'm not i understand
the situation but it is happening and i
think we need teeth in this
so that we can enforce
and let the hospitals know in no
uncertain terms that they have to deal
with family and i'm sure it's annoying
i'm sure it's terrible having you know a
lot of these families brought were
visited visitation brought coveted into
the some of these facilities
but we have to work it out and we have
to let the hospitals know that the the
there needs to be visitation access and
what happened in the beginning of it can
never happen again
my conversations with various medical
administrator
colleagues in much larger and similar
size facilities is we had a learning
curve
i wound up doing debriefing
of my staff members individually because
of the stress
that they were under i'm not qualified
to diagnose ptsd but i know it when i
see it
and
needed
the safety valve of debriefing because
they themselves even reported themselves
to me saying my attitude is stinking and
i just said something to somebody i
shouldn't have understood but let's not
repeat it so yeah there's been a
learning curve and we want to encourage
mike
i want to apologize for my poor choice
of words there was a lot of hard
feelings from administration not only to
patients but to their own staff
i've heard sad stories about that and i
was guilty of that too representative
thank you so much for your apology
representative leon
um thank you mr chairman
i actually took the patient bill of
rights out of the statute it's two pages
long if we add this language to it it'll
go from a two-page document to three and
a half pages
on my amendment on the second page line
26 it references it
but we also have lines 12 and 13 where
it requires each healthcare facility to
post on its website the informational
materials explaining the rights in this
section that should include the written
hospital policies that will lead to a
denial
there's nothing keeping them from having
that as a booklet or pamphlet or
something on the wall that says check
for most recent updates but this is our
policy and this is where you find our
most recent visitor policy
this
we're feeling all of these hard feelings
here in this room it's hard to be a
healthcare professional and it's hard to
be a patient and it's even harder to be
a loved one that doesn't know what's
going on
i think that this is going to help us
heal and i know that there are some big
deep um divides here on how to go about
it so if i ca may i make a motion mr
no okay
the chair realizes he's likely to be the
casting vote the chair calls on
i would move
amendment
representative weber has moved amendment
h is there a second to that
representative
soloway and we may speak to this and
[Music]
i did a quick
thing silly uh i added 10 19 and 946 and
divided by two
i'm sorry i'm not understanding what you
what i'm trying to say is i like them
both
and i can't get them both
and what i'm hoping is that
whichever amendment triumphs
the other amendment
will also be heard
by the senate as they get ready to work
on this bill should it pass the house
there's good stuff in both
but i have to pick one
and i just did
anything else
anybody
i think i've talked the issue to death
well it's my turn
and i'm not going to
the motion before us is amendment 0946
moved by representative weber and
seconded by representative soloway
and before i asked the clerk to call the
role i just want to reiterate i do
really appreciate
the unique parts of both and hope
in the future that they can be
incorporated into one with the clerk
please call the roll
representative leon
no
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman no representative
folsom no representative kelsey now
representative king
no representative cofoult no
representative delemus
representative weber yes representative
mckay yes representative snow
representative knurk yes representative
soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant yes
representative pearson yes the motion
carries 11 to 10. the chair recognizes
representative weber for another motion
mr chairman i would move out to pass on
yes
my vice chairs requested a republican
caucus
could i
could i suggest that we have a lunch
break and you can have your caucus so
people aren't just sitting here waiting
for
it's it's let's have a luncheon caucus
break that's my
that's my request so that
the rest of us are not sitting here
waiting
and at what time are we returning mr
chairman
what were we just working on hospitals
we are back and i am going to recess our
executive session on 1439 i realize
there is a motion on the floor but we
are going now start
executive session again
on house bill 1180 which also has a
motion on the floor pending a ruling
from the clerk of the house whether
should the amendment pass the bill we
would vote on
may legally be considered the answer and
i will let our committee assist
researcher fourth floor denizen give the
and notwithstanding a reference to
administration of motor vehicle laws we
may proceed with this i trust that
in enrolled bills they'll change any
words that that are just ridiculous
the motion before us moved by
representative gay and seconded by
representative acton
i just wanted to make a comment about
enrolled bills they don't
they only correct statutory references
they can't take out a whole
portion of what we have passed thank you
so if you
are concerned as i am about
why we are even addressing this in motor
vehicles you should vote no on the
amendment um and then no on the
underlying bill
everything else whether you agree or
disagree with it seems to be an order
and again my thought is when this goes
over to the senate should they catch
this
then there will be a committee of
conference
so the motion before us removed by
representative gay seconded by
representative acton is the amendment
i also don't understand why it was
anything in motor vehicle laws
would it be difficult
would it be worth waiting for to go ask
they do work quickly
christina do you have any knowledge as
to how this phrase managed to get into
this
could you call
there's a code here as to which lawyer
it is and i can never figure out who's
whom
or who's who
okay
so we will we will do that we will find
out why that is in there and it would be
in order to
[Music]
do that representative weber i'm just
going to express a certain amount of
frustration here and that we were given
orders from you last week to have
everything in order for today and some
of our
bills are now working on their fourth or
fifth amendments in the last two days
and
uh
i'm very concerned about time for today
i know some of us have
time commitments
and
i'm also concerned about tomorrow but
there it is well we're not going to come
back tomorrow but i share your
frustration and um
i may be enabling some of the reasons
for our frustration to which i apologize
uh then
i would i am considering taking the
session on 1180 off
while you're getting the answer to that
so this closes
the exact session on 1180 until we get
an answer to that
um we're waiting on your thing uh
the exact session
on house bill 1080 relative to the
rights of conscience for medical
professionals
uh there are no amendments to this
and
i call on myself since it's my bill to
move otp
okay thank you very much delay miss
during the hearing you may remember um i
brought up the question
that there are numbers of medical
professionals who for deeply held
reasons of conscience
cannot participate in
an abortion
and
there were numbers of i thought very
very helpful suggestions on ways to
broaden this to
beyond simply abortion
or or and
not just medical professionals but
counseling professionals in other words
turn it into a a very large bill that
recognizes the
rights of conscience
in a number of people in the helping
professions
and i thought that was
very very good certainly
to me to be desired
but at the end i felt let's deal with
this one particular issue
and over the summer perhaps people of
goodwill may wish to work on a
rights of conscience for counselors
rights of conscience for medical
professionals in other areas but since
we are
most likely to be hearing from the u.s
supreme court on abortion rulings in the
next months
and the various states are dealing with
that in one way or the other
this is a hot button issue
i would i would end my presentation
by saying when massachusetts had which
it stopped having recently but when it
had
very strict
[Music]
rights of conscience
on abortion for medical people
it did not hurt the medical profession
in that state they were ranked amongst
the top as they still are lots of people
still wanted to practice in
massachusetts it will not in any way
negatively impact
people in new hampshire
so that's the presentation of the
my concern
about the bill
is that
currently
anybody who has a problem with their
conscience has the right to seek
different employment different
circumstances
it's not as if medical personnel for
example aren't desperately wanted in
every single solitary area in every
single solitary field
and
my training was that your conscience was
something that you wrestled with you
consulted
and following your conscience is not
always easy
something
that
i think
the issue with this bill is that it
codifies the rights
of conscience
of people whose conscience dictates one
certain
procedure
and one way of proceeding
while at the same time the rights of
conscience of people who disagree with
them
is already made illegal so there is no
possibility
of medical providers
who think that it is an appropriate and
necessary practice for example
to help
people who are stuck in an impossible
situation after 24 weeks of pregnancy
they don't have the rights of conscience
they're it's they are prohibited
people currently are not prohibited from
following their consciences in this
direction they're just not protected for
it
and i think treating different people's
consciences
differently in that way
i also am concerned that as written
this could have the
effect and i grant you it's tenuous but
i don't see any way of preventing it
you have somebody who gets a
job at a reproductive health care center
and then says oh
i've had a crisis of conscience
i no longer want to participate in
abortion care
and they get to keep their job and keep
their pay
and
not be able to be discharged even though
they're not providing any of the core
functions of what they were hired to do
and i think that is reprehensible
so
there are a lot of other reasons but i'm
going to stop there and say i'm voting
against this bill let me speak to the
three that you did mention
increasingly
doctors do not have standalone practices
the one i supervise is a dinosaur we
have three pcps and we are an entity to
ourselves
most people coming out of medical
schools have to work for chains now with
numbers and numbers and numbers of
doctors
and
we have heard testimony and we have done
our investigation to see that um
many of these would not hire
somebody with an objection to abortion
so the job market
may be limited this would say to those
people if you have many doctors on your
staff you can do workarounds as i know
some jobs do to give jewish people
friday night and saturday often
christian people sunday off there's
workarounds and
secondly um this bill does not seek to
address one way or the other the
abortion rules put in place by house
bill second two that's their thing
that's another bill this is dealing with
certain things it's not dealing with
other people other rights other jobs
and then thirdly um
i've never met anybody and and i am
quite active in the pro-life movement i
have never met anybody
who when conscience
suddenly um has not suddenly but
conscience now changes and one is
anti-abortion while working at a place
that does abortions who stays there they
voluntarily leave i have never heard of
anybody who has stayed and then started
to demand rights finally this language
is
obviously way smarter than i am and has
been put
into legislation in some states and is
trying to be in some others
representative shapiro
yes thank you um
i understand that many medical
facilities there are
or many of them are large and there are
various functions and people could find
other positions but
in an agency such as planned parenthood
which has a limited scope
if someone decided
by conscience or whatever that they were
no willing no longer willing to deal
with
even take abortion out of the equation
but contraceptives
my understanding of this bill is that if
they chose to and i don't know why they
would chose choose to accept to be
obstructionist
that it would be illegal for planned
move this person along say that they
couldn't work there anymore have a
amicable parting
and
that just to me seems to defy common
sense
as well as being
contrary to protecting
businesses
planned parenthood isn't literally a
business but there are a organization
and so
i wouldn't have any problem with the
part
of this bill which i believe addresses
um
not allowing for consequences at a
medical board or any kind of board of
practice
but the part about employment
um protecting the person from protecting
the
person from being let go of employment
um just
defies logic to me i just don't
understand how we could do that
there's no evidence that this has ever
happened
well there is no evidence that anybody
who's worked in a facility like that has
suddenly decided to stay and be a jerk
representative shapiro as you pointed
out earlier today we often do things
ahead of time so that
to head off problems um i appreciate
this is just you know this is just a
potential problem
okay thank you
anyone else
this is the kind of bill that uh we
could either
just start voting on or we could talk
for about the next six months and
you know i i don't want to say you can't
speak but i'm just going to suggest
we've
we've really spoken on
this issue a lot and
my encouragement as we move to a vote
but if somebody wishes to speak
representative woods please do so uh yes
i just from the physicians perspective
and the pa's perspective since they're
both under the aegis of the board of
medicine
the
nrsa
physicians have to meet the standard of
the american code of
medical ethics
in there it states very specifically
uh this very issue and i won't go into
all the details and read you the
legalese
but indeed
the physician well i'll just say a
physician may decline to establish a
patient physician relationship with a
prospective patient or provide specific
care to an existing patient certain
limited circumstances and in there it
talks about just this issue of the
conscious
decline
and so from that perspective and i can't
speak for nurses i can't speak for other
providers
but under the board of medicine
the physicians and the pas are have to
meet that standard which includes
as a backup you know this ethical
standard and the and the role of the
what if the facility let's say a large
doc in the box with 15
providers
were to put pressure on a physician
to participate to assist in
uh that that has happened uh and i can't
tell you the outcome but it did go to
court
uh and it varies from state to state uh
i think there's only
i'll say three there may be more but
three that i know of
that have the ama guides as
that's the standard that's being used
and so i don't know about the other
states they don't have that to fall back
on so i can't i can't
really answer your question
seeing no further hands then the
question before us
is house bill 1080 the rights of
conscience
for medical professionals is its title
ought to pass move by the chair seconded
by representative
delemus
would the clerk please call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative co fault yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative freitas oh she's not here
today
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk no representative
soloway
representative cannon no representative
nutter upham no representative shapiro
no
representative woods no representative
merchant no representative pearson yes
11 10 carries the bill carries
11 10 and representative woods i
appreciate if you when you get a chance
to uh you sending me the items that you
referenced sure thank you
sends the uh exact session on 1080
yes i will write the blurb
minority
uh
who's doing it
weber that would be me that would be you
the chair um humbly asks representative
leon to tell me what we're now opening
an exec session on
thank you mr chairman we are opening
executive session on house bill 1439
thank you
and during the lunch hour and i am
delivering not the penultimate but the
ultimate amendment that i have to offer
today
this is it um
what here we go one second we are on
no you're right we have something on the
floor don't we we have a motion
we do we have a motion on the floor i
think it might be helpful
for people who are about to vote on the
motion if they knew because none of us
have heard about it
what the alternative might be
thank you
thank you i will pass around amendment
what this does is oh sorry these are
supposed to go to you leah there you go
representative cushman um if you look to
page two
could we please wait until all of us
have it i can't listen
and hear
what's going on i need to have a piece
of paper in front of me i know
so
that's your plan
the changes are on the back page lines
starting at line 12.
yes line 12 through 18.
this is the change line page 2 lines 12
to 18. it's a change by virtue of
everything up to that point is the same
as we had in 1019
representative weber
and this is the change solely line
12 to 18 and nothing after that has
changed is was that all in the original
bill as well or something after 18
change the only change was lines 12
they look like they're still reading a
representative leon tell us what this
new
and final version of amendment
brings to the table
thank you mr chairman
we had great discussion about how rights
and responsibilities aren't much unless
you know about them
this
adds that the patient bill of rights
needs to be available on the facility
website and on the wall and the hospital
visitation policy detailing the rights
and responsibilities created by the
section and the limitations placed on
those rights by written hospital policy
to be available on the website and in
the rooms
that way it that way any of the policies
that are limiting them aren't a surprise
to people in the facility or before they
enter them that way the responsibility
to
not
be
not interfere with other patients and
not be disruptive or threatening is also
clear to the patient and their visitors
the motive or the impetus to this as i
recall was a recalcitrant member of your
very caucus who wanted the thing on the
wall and uh dug in his heels accordingly
and over a nice lunch uh this amendment
seems to mollify him would you agree i
sure would hope so
thank you
representative weber
and for all the reasons that have been
discussed
again and again and again it fails to
satisfy any of the concerns that were
raised with any of the previous layout
amendments so
i will be voting against i i will be
voting for ought to pass as amended with
the weber amendment which is the actual
motion which is in front of us it is
and
should that fail because i can count
i will be voting against this amendment
and against ought to pass
i don't see any reason for rehashing all
of that because nothing's going to
change
the motion before us is amendment
0946 to house bill 1439
moved by representative weber and
seconded by representative soloway
and
one person
we have voted on the amendment and the
pending motion was ought to pass as
amended on with house with amendment
zero four nine six h
that had been moved and seconded it was
moved by representative webber and
seconded by representative pearson he
did didn't he oh yes i didn't write that
down so that has been
done would we need a reconsideration
okay dawn breaks
apparently the in in fact the motion
before us
is ought to pass
as amended
on house bill
by
represe representative weber moved and
somebody oh me representative pearson
seconded it and now that is what we will
vote on madam clerk please
representative leon no representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman no representative
folsom no representative kelsey now
representative king
no representative cofoult no
representative delemus
representative weber
yes representative mckay yes
representative snow
representative knurk
yes representative soloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter uppam yes representative shapiro
yes representative woods yes
representative merchant
yes
uh
motion fails tend to motion fails 10 to
11.
now the chair recognizes representative
leon
for
a motion
thank you mr chairman i move to adopt
representative
state your point of order um
we are therefore voting on an amendment
to a bill which we have just defeated is
the bill is still in play on the other
any further discussion
the amendment before us now is
amendment 1029 to house bill 1439
moved by representative leon and
seconded by representative
kelsey
and would the clerk please call the role
on this amendment
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk no representative
soloway
representative cannon
no
representative nutter upham no
representative shapiro
representative woods no
what representative merchant
no representative pearson yes
the amendment carries 11 to 10. chair
recognizes uh
representative leon for a further motion
thank you mr chairman i move house bill
1439 ought to pass as amen with
amendment by as amended by
2022-1029h
and do i see a second
i will
seeing that there is none
the motion before us is
house bill 1439 as amended by
2022-1029-h moved by representative leon
and seconded by representative folsom
the motion is ought to pass is amended
the clerk may call the rule
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes representative cofoult yes
representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay representative snow
no representative knurk no
representative soloway
representative cannon no representative
nutter upham no representative shapiro
no representative woods no
representative merchant no
representative pearson yes
ends the executive
session minority report on
is your minority report with your
i'm still thinking about it
i'm pretty sure it's going to be the one
with my
minority amendment but
okay
what's left
mark were you going to do
chair were you going to do that
confusion about this other amendment
um
no but i thought if you wanted to have
any time to deal with it we need to get
that done so that we could have time to
deal
open the executive session or continue
it on house bill 1180 and the chair
recognizes representative leon who
will inform us about line eight to the
amendment why it talks about motor
vehicle laws
thank you mr chairman the motor vehicle
laws are long and involved and the
details of them are a bit hard to tease
out however the manchester school board
policy cited the motor vehicle laws and
that is one of the places where
gender and sex are recognized by the
state and when it speaks to whether or
not the state
is differentiating
it makes sense to be in those areas
where the state does in fact
differentiate
so the inference would be in spite of it
sounding very contra intuitive there's a
reason why they build drafter lawyer put
it in there yes and because when we look
to other states like florida they've
determined that your biological sex is
whatever the state declares you what you
declares you are so it would be the
florida determined that whatever's on
your driver's license is your biological
sex
which is great for some things not so
great for looking at
risks of different medical therapies and
that sort of thing so the recognition
the recognition has
in general has has broader applications
but we're only looking here to athletic
competitions that has nothing to do with
hormone therapy or anything else that's
very important as well
thank you for that clarification we
actually have a motion on the floor for
this amendment moved by representative
gay and seconded by representative acton
and we can continue to have any
discussion
there was some discussion earlier today
that this amendment also dealt with some
of the concerns raised by the department
of corrections but i don't see anything
in the amendment about that the
amendment removes anything to do with
the department of correction for the
very reason of their testifying
that is now out of the bell should the
okay i guess i didn't interest
it is done because of their concerns
so we acknowledged that in this
amendment in this amendment i didn't see
representative
weber give it a shot uh
you don't see it in here because it was
in the original bill
and this amendment replaces everything
so
it's taken out anything in the bill
okay
you may
and and that's why
because it solves issues for the
department of corrections and for people
the public accommodation bit the the
very squishy language about places of
personal privacy
kevin only knows what that means
i will vote for the amendment because it
solves some of the problem but not for
the bill because it retains a huge
amount of the problem with respect
to
athletics
which in my opinion i agree with those
who've spoken before who think that's
best left
to the policy
making bodies for
athletics
is it not true however that the
amendment does not make that policy it
allows
local
areas to have a different policy if they
choose
the motion before us is
to house bill
moved by representative
gay and seconded by
you can take a minute
for the clerk's benefit
you may
speak so the
what i'm trying to wrap my head around
is i i recognize that we want to make
sure that we can differentiate but the
question is with this amendment are we
saying we can only differentiate for
athletic competitions
um i'm i'm really torn up about that
because
if we're saying that that's the only
time you can differentiate i sat in on a
data subcommittee on the council for
suicide prevention and when they were
looking at it and trying to do the death
records for suicide reports a lot of
times they say unknown because they
don't know
and
new hampshire's data on transgender
suicide and suicidal ideation is
absolutely terrible because we don't ask
those questions and we don't have a way
to answer that
i would love to have data that says new
hampshire is better than the rest of the
country on this
but if we're worse than it we need to
know that too
and i'm afraid that by saying that it
only
specifying that it's this case an
athletic competition that it then does
away with the opportunity to
differentiate in other areas that are
really important because
transitioning is a medical process and
the medical issues that come with it are
important
and i don't want to
i don't want to cause more problems with
this than we solve
because this is this is a really
challenging issue
and i respect the girls who lose their
scholarships and i respect the fact that
that
that on some things data matters and we
need to be able to to identify
differentiate and i respect that we have
young women that dominate on the
wrestling mats too and in jiu jitsu
especially in these grappling sports
where it's not just strength it's also
finesse
i'm just worried that this narrows it
too
much do you believe the original bill
unamended
would be helpful to the concerns
in part for data that you raise
um i do think that it would be
helpful um the i don't
actually with our right of personal
privacy and article 2b
i'd call my privacy in intimate space so
maybe there's a reason to to respect
that there
i think that the original bill
goes further to it because it draws more
more areas and not just just athletic
competition
so i think that i think there's less of
a risk with the bill as introduced than
there is with it if we amend it this way
in terms of the
conversations i had with rockingham
county jail and the documents that were
produced from others
in the original bill when it talks about
criminal
incarceration
it doesn't mandate anything it just says
that nothing is prohibited
so if they want to keep doing what
they're doing they can keep doing what
they're doing this doesn't say they
can't in my reading of it unless i'm
representative leon so in some other
states they've they've held that because
one area was carved out and the other
wasn't that that meant the legislature
only intended the carve out
okay representative canark
yes i'd like to reflect upon the
data that representative leon brought up
about suicide
it is true that transgender
individuals do have a higher rate of
suicide
but it's far higher and
those who are not
affirmed those who face constant
discrimination
because they have gender dysphoria which
means they don't feel comfortable with
their current identity
you exacerbate that when you
continue to discriminate against them so
if they are
feeling gendered as a female and that is
a persistent and consistent identity not
just that day
but you tell them they cannot
go into a female restroom and they must
go into a male restroom
that will increase their rate of suicide
and that's that's well documented around
the country so even if we don't have
great little numbers in new hampshire
there's not a whole lot of reason to
believe that we're going to be any
different than any other part of the
country
representative leon thank you mr
chairman when you look to the data
internationally
unfortunately the suicide rates in
in thailand where it's a very accepted
lifestyle and also in sweden where
there's not the stigma that we see here
that we still see here the rates are
still very similar
unfortunately it seems that
that the stigma is one portion of it but
it's not the it's not the only part
the question
it's not the only part of it
you may respond
to i don't i think it's very
disingenuous to compare different
countries because there's going to be
differences all together what you look
at is in this country
same setup
those who have had their gender
uh questions affirmed versus those who
continue to face discrimination
for example at one point a couple of
years ago we were the number was cited
that
transgender people who had undergone
gender affirming surgery at a higher
rate of suicide therefore that was a
problem well there was a higher rate of
suicide compared to normal controls but
it was still lower than those who had
not
had gender affirming surgery one has to
be comparing apples to apples and not
apples to oranges so comparing us to
thailand
is not a valid comparison we should
stick with
those who continue to face
discrimination and
shunning by their community by their
religious organizations and by their
family
versus those who are affirmed in their
feelings
that's the valid
comparison
the the challenges
that
representative knurk has raised is is
and
i'm concerned with this bill
if a if a
if a child a transgender child goes out
for a team and is told they can't
compete by a
local entity
by a public entity
is
they may be depressed just as depressed
as a child as a another
genetic girl that plays however
that transgender person
will have been judged by the community
the public entity
and they will have to deal with that as
well
so the impact on them and the potential
of suicide is even greater at that point
because now they have no fallback
they've been told by
after listening to this
conversation
i
begin to realize this is a relatively
complex area
and i don't think we're in a position
today at least i know i'm not
to take something so complex
and to take a simple point about that
complexity
and make a rule on it
cannon
i would like to give
the committee an idea of what we're
dealing with as far as the size of the
population
in new hampshire we have about six
that's not even one percent of the
population that's one third of a percent
of the population
the number of students transgender
students in school
is less than 500 across the entire state
the number of students in that community
that actually play sports
is substantially less
so we are talking about putting a
statute in place
for a very very tiny number of people in
the state of new hampshire
this is this is
focused attention on a small group of
people instead of working with the
policy boards for the communities for
that's for the
schools
which they do they can control the
policies within the school
the the state intercollastics inter
scholastic sports
athletic association has a policy they
have put in place it's a very good one
the ncaa has a policy in place
to support
transgender people
in our colleges and universities
that's where
it should be decided consistently across
organizations for the
small number of people that will
actually be impacted by this if we put
this into statute
the way it
is
a very small number of transgender
students and put them on notice they are
different
than other students in this school
because they won't be allowed to compete
even though we're not taking into
consideration
that the number of transgender students
that can actually compete at a very high
level is very small
there are many
transgender students competing in sports
already that compete head-to-head with
their female peers
there is no
difference in their ability especially
those students that have been on hormone
blockers since the age of 13
they have not developed at the same rate
as other students
so we may be talking about a couple
handfuls of students
that can compete at a very high level
that are transgender
and for those students we should be
depending on our
on our
organizations that are responsible for
policies to find a way to work with
those students and the schools to make
it a safe environment for all in fact
both the
nhiaa and the ncaa
have in their statement they recognize
that there are
male and female students and transgender
male and female students and that all
people
must be able to compete
in their
their policies are directed to that to
keep a level playing field
in the sports environment especially for
interscholastic
um
situations thank you
representative leon
thank you for that representative that
was really powerful and really important
and i thank you
um that last part you spoke to the ncaa
recognizing the the different categories
of students and accommodating them
appropriately
the
the spill doesn't say that you need to
it doesn't give any requirements to do
anything differently there are some some
states that the way that it's
interpreting it it would say that you
couldn't even interpret things the way
that the ncaa requires it to
because some other states in california
they've ruled that what your driver's
license is is what is is your identity
and your biologic sex so in that you
couldn't have the accommodations
for a transgendered athlete in ncaa if
the state only recognizes you
as your
affirmed gender
as your biologic sex so it would it does
away with some of those clarifications
and some of those
those details um the risk here is that
our courts might interpret this the way
that other states have interpreted it um
and that that ends up taking away more
people's rights because they're applying
a one-size-fits-all if this is what your
driver's license says this is what you
are and we know we're all so much more
complex than our driver's license
i'm sitting here i don't know the best
way to do this because i don't want our
state to come down
and say that we can't have any of these
differentiations but i feel like there's
a risk too if we completely get rid of
this because
we might you know
because there's consequences both ways
and
yeah
so would not the answer be an interim
study and i did see a representative
merchant over there waving his hand and
i'd second him there is a motion already
on the floor to move the amendment
okay all we can do is either the uh
motioner and second have the right to
withdraw
if they do not wish to do that we have
to vote the amendment and then we can go
you may withdraw
the motion then you may make another
motion if you're recognized to do so
okay then i respectfully withdraw
motion to pass on the amendment 959
representative acton you had seconded
that means i asked the parliamentarian a
question does it have to be both of them
agree
oh you're blinking look at you
there's
everybody who's not talking shut your
mic off a challenge everything
okay i believe it's the the the
moving party and the second or both have
to withdraw so
um
that's what i understand
yeah in the which case though on the
other hand there
i believe and i'm just working this
through so if anybody has any other
ideas let me know
uh
we can adopt the amendment and if nobody
chooses to move on to pass as amended
somebody could make a different motion
that is where i was going i just wanted
to check with
your much greater wisdom and experience
in mind
the status of the amendment now
has the seconder
with the uh mover withdrawn
my parliamentarians research has told me
that
representative acton by default can
become the mover of the amendment and it
will need to have a second
and representative gay now becomes the
second so now the motion is back in the
amendment is now back in play with the
motion of ought to pass
the amendment
the motion is the amendment
any further discussion
having
it is flipped
we needed a second or you became the
mover by not withdrawing we needed a
seconder if so happens uh representative
gay becomes the seconder so it is
flipped
the motion before us is amendment 9 5 9
on house bill 1180 now
officially moved by acton and seconded
by gay and
the clerk may call the role on the
amendment
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
yes representative king yes
representative cofoult
yes
representative delemus yes
representative weber representative
mckay
representative snow yes representative
knerk
yes
representative salloway
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham yes representative shapiro
no
representative woods yes
yes
representative pearson yes
it carries 20 to 1.
20 to 1 the motion
has
carried and now the chair will be
representative gay
a move ought to pass
on house bill 1180 as
amended
by
a second
representative canark
i
have difficulties with this bill even as
amended because of the testimony from
the department of justice the assistant
attorney general sean glock came
and pointed out that this that
we have our transgender rights uh that
were codified a couple of years ago
and that
this bill
that that
prohibits discrimination
but this bill
allows discrimination
and with that in mind it leads to a
conflict in the statute so
again
the previous bill prohibits
discrimination with
gender identity this bill allows them to
that is a conflict in law
um he stated that very clearly they
didn't take a position but
that is going to be a problem in terms
of how
representative shapiro thank you mr
chairman i think as we so often say
there uh either way we vote on this
there are
um
consequences and there are benefits and
in this case um the way i see it is the
you know there might be a case where
there's actually a
very strong transgender female who um
has an unfair advantage although
um the chairman said he has an unaware
of one even though he collects um i'm
not aware of one in new hampshire
specifically yes right correctly correct
so that could be a case i acknowledge
that um
but on the other side the consequence is
that we are marginalizing a group of
people
and potentially affecting their
self-esteem
in the extreme case even affecting their
mental health
so either way we turn there's a
benefit and a
consequence
i'm going to vote against this because
i think number one it's more important
to protect
those people who are marginalized
and are vulnerable
and the other thing is i think that we
there's certainly some young
representatives here but a lot of us are
old and i think
i think the younger generation has moved
on with this
there's a great deal of acceptance of
youth in schools who are very different
that would not have been the case
20 years ago 10 years ago but i think
younger generations have really moved on
i i often um get the job of playing um
pretend with my seven-year-old
granddaughter
because nobody else has the patience to
do it so we're sitting there with um
stuffed animals and dolls and talking to
each other and um
that's pretend and my granddaughter
frankie says
you know i'll refer to sally and she'll
say that's not sally that's george
and i'll say frankie you told me it was
sally you told me it was a girl and she
says to me grandpa you can be anything
you want to be
and
i think that is a sign of the
generations to come that will make these
kinds of things
irrelevant eventually
and i think we can make it irrelevant
representative merchant
thank you
mr uh thank you for that testimony um
representative shabaro
when i look at this bill even the
amendment itself
it's what they call what i call an
oxymoron
because what i'm trying to get to is
that in this we're identifying people to
be
biologically one way or the other
yet this in the statute says we're not
going to use that differentiation
to prohibit them
in competing
in either any other sport so i don't
stand behind this whole thing is on one
side of the coin we're going to say well
you belong to this one listen but you
can
at the end of the day
choose whatever side you want to be on
so it to me it's a it's a paradox or
maybe even an oxymoron
is that
one side of the coin which claim to
people you have to decide which team you
want to be on oh by the way you can
participate on any team you want
so it doesn't make any sense the way
this bill is written
for us to pass it i go back to i said
before i would think
with the
complexity
the emotions and the passions we all
have
is to go to interim study
so that
we can take a deep dive into the subject
better hear from people from all sides
of the fence
and make
a decision that's appropriate
and not to take the time today to try to
when this bill
i received
hundreds of emails you may not have
received them
i know you have received many from from
upset people
i've received
messages from
people of my era and your era
people who have lived
um
trent as transgender people for all of
their lives for many many years
because this bill
treats them as second-class citizens
it makes them feel incredibly small and
victimized by a whole system that says
they shouldn't exist
in just discussing this bill
we're telling transgender people that
they can't be transgender people
we need to make the decision for them
and that's wrong
i put up
i beat myself up because i didn't want
to be a transgender p person because
society was against me and that's what i
see here it's the same thing
that's what transgender people have to
deal with every day
and here we are in the state house
discussing legislation that puts them on
notice that they can't be who they are
i have a 10 year old daughter i've said
that before
she's athletic and when she gets into
high school she'll
i believe that
this situation
where
trans people can take part in in a sport
like this takes away her rights her
rights to to fairly compete in a sport
and and have the chance of winning
and i i don't hear any discussion of the
rights taken away from other people now
i have supported
glbt rights for from the get-go no one
can say i haven't i ran for in a senate
primary as a openly
pro-gay marriage republican in 2012. and
i got 24 of the vote not six or seven
you know so i've i understand the issues
but in this case it's it's a matter of
basic fairness
should my daughter
have to compete
with biological males and sports now
i i say that
we need to move move into this
in a
step-by-step fashion week and in this
case i think this all we're doing here
is allowing
local local bodies to use that in as
part of their decision making
and that's we're not forcing them to do
anything we're not mandating anything
we're simply allowing it
and um
just discussing that we're being
told that we're we're
damaging people and we're causing
suicides the hyperbole is getting a
little out of control here let's step
back to this issue is the way i see is a
basic level of fairness for my daughter
my wife's very concerned about this and
many people are but they don't even want
to talk about it because they're
intimidated
so that's let's take a step back and
look at the narrow thing that we're
doing it relates to sports only
and it's related to fair basic issue of
fairness
i sit on somersworth's school board
in fact we're going to be
looking at
transgender policy policy jbab in the
it is completely
modifiable
depending on the school district
a school district can decide for itself
how it wants to support transgender
children
in fact there's one district in new
hampshire
with their administration has been told
if you have a child that identifies as
transgender
we need to report it to their parents
talk about being scared to death
the kids
especially transgender kids who have
drawn have grown up with their peers
male or female
want to compete
with those same people
if there's a problem with that
the school administration has the right
to work with those
kids and their families to find the
solution
if it goes beyond that
they can take it to court
should we be putting in a statute that
regulates what they can or can't do
or should we leave it to the local
entities
as has is identified in this bill leave
it to them which they can already do
and take it to court if it goes beyond
that
that's that's all i'm saying i want your
kids to be able to play
and to make if there's an issue
bring it up at the school boards
bring it up to the local court
have them make the decision
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
representative cannon it sounds like you
support local decision making on this
and i don't see anything in here that
would change the local decision making
is there something that i'm missing here
i believe that this just clarifies that
the local school boards are in fact
allowed to make those decisions
that's right
and that's
excuse me mr chair can i answer that
you may
that's right
local control
but if we do put legislation in place
that's a much higher level we are
putting something in place that is going
to tell a transgender
person that they're unwanted
we
it's
here's the nub
currently in our statutes the default is
non-discrimination
it's recognizing people for who they
believe themselves to be
and it is affirming
if we change the law
taking
a right that has been extended
away
and we are becoming less affirming
and we are putting more roadblocks in
the way
of a kid
evolving into the person
that they want to be
so
that's that's the problem here
people say well it's just permissive
well it's perm what it's permitting is
discrimination and i understand that the
issues are complicated
and the issues are scary
and the issues are politicized
but
what we're doing is permitting
more discrimination
rather than less
we are permitting it
but we're still permitting it the
question has or the statement has been
made it should be decided at the local
thank you mr chairman
for the record i would like everybody to
know that i am in favor of biological
sex
having enjoyed it several times in my
life
so i certainly can't speak for the
um i'm
old enough to remember
when the vocabulary changed
and i believe it was 1956
when christine jorgensen
changed
gender
and since then over the last 65 years
the language has changed and we are
debating a language that is now
thoroughly
out of date
we don't no longer speak about sex we
speak about gender
in polite company frankly we don't say
queer
or dike
we talk about gender preference
we talk about people's gender identity
we talk about gender assignment
for children who are born differently
we talk about intersex
members of our community we talked about
people with gender fluidity fluidity
we talk about people with gender
dysphoria but the language has changed
and we are debating in a language that
is totally out of date and is
inappropriate for our wisdom in this
legislature
i'm going to step out of the closet for
you all
and i'm going to tell you that even
though i am elected from a democratic
district and run as a democrat
i am what is called a dino
democrat in name only
the fact of the matter is that i would
be a libertarian except that i find that
the libertarians are more to the left of
me
and i want you to understand that that
means that i do not wish to have
the heavy hand of government
probing my pants
or the pants of my children or
grandchildren in an attempt to label me
or them
as something or another
this is a local issue it's to be decided
by families perhaps by school boards but
certainly not by
a heavy-handed legislature
though it is
heavy-handed of me to say so
i don't wish to have a gender
determining tattoo
on my left arm i don't wish to be told
that i need to wear
a pink triangle or a yellow star i think
we should get out of people's private
business
i think we should interim study this
bill and say that we have examined it
closely but we are the wrong place for
such decisions to be made thank you for
listening
representative i find some of that
language shaming
you speak of we no longer say
there's a lot of language that you use
that i
recognize many people including many of
my friends are comfortable with
i am not
and many of my friends are not
and please do not marginalize me or my
friends
you may respond if you wish if i have
offended you sir i deeply apologize
i suspect however that you know me well
enough to understand that my community
is extraordinarily diverse and i walk
proudly and well with them
but i thank you for the comment you did
not have to say that sir because i've
known that from almost the time i met
you but thank you
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
uh
now if our default is that we are
affirming
then that means
it legally
um and that we do not discriminate and
we did hear testimony from an attorney
that
the way to determine if discrimination
has occurred is by replacing
the gender that one is identifying
with and
so if a student wants to participate in
girls sports and he is biologically male
but identifies as female if you changed
his
uh
what he wants to do to the other gender
and would that still fly then no it's
so but if if we are
in the position where schools believe in
sports regulatory bodies believe that
they must default to affirming someone's
um self-reported
gender identity
then
wouldn't it be possible for johnny who
is a sprinter
but
can't make
the final cut for track
and is discouraged to then go and say
well i'm going to identify as jane now
and i'm going to join the girls track
team
because now the default is that we have
to affirm so in that situation we need
to give on a case-by-case basis the
ability for these bodies to make the
determination if that is fair it's a
balancing of rights it is not by any
means to say that transgenders should
not exist but there are scenarios where
this can be abused or where it's just
not appropriate especially if a boy is
well developed through male puberty and
possesses the the skeleton
skeletal features and muscle features of
a
nearly matured boy
would be a scenario where i think
the school or the
sport regulating body has an interest of
differentiating between biological sex
and that is all that this does it does
not say that in every situation they
have to do that it doesn't even say that
in any situation they have to it just
says that they do have an interest and
they don't have to default to
um affirming
i'm going to suggest that we draw this
to a close because at this point no
one's going to change anyone's mind but
um i would like to give representative
thank you mr chair
um
i understand your concerns
representative
in school
the um
the document that i mentioned
in the nhiaa addresses your issues they
do flag that a student
can't
change back and forth
between male and female teams
when they're in school especially in
high school
i am not clear on their on their
definition of
of
whether they should be on hormones or
not
so there is work being done
there is a recognition that there's a
difference
those policy organizations are working
on it to address it
our voices to those organizations
to help make it better for all students
is needed
i don't think we should be making those
decisions here
i think we should be making them with
the organizations who are charted to do
it
throughout the state
without requiring
state legislative efforts
to control what they do
if we put it in statute
their hands will be tied
they won't be able to change it
when they should have the flexibility to
work within the standards communities
in the sports community to make it
standard
across the community and to make it safe
and competitive for all
the motion before us
on house bill 1180 is ought to pass
with amendment 0959
moved by representative gay
and seconded by representative acton
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton yes
representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey
representative king yes representative
cofoult yes representative delemus
representative weber
representative mckay no
representative snow no
representative knurk no
representatives holloway no
representative cannon no representative
nutter upham no
representative shapiro no representative
woods no
representative merchant
no representative pearson yes
the motion passes
11 to 10
with representative gay please writing
appropriate
uh representative cannon is
this ends the hearing excuse me the
exact session on house bill 1180
we're not quite done yet i don't believe
there are any more bills left to be done
but i sure like
and my clerk and vice chair say no and
if anybody else
can pull one out of the ether that we
should have looked at let me know
with that in mind uh representative
canark had something he would like to
address if you could give us um
my friend
like
the cliff notes
and then we'll decide if we wish
maybe it may be a boot point i had heard
from um
kate oregon
that the
speaker had ruled that the amendment on
1437 was non-germane but then i heard
that that has been changed that now has
been ruled germane so we do not need to
revisit it
thank you how's that for cliff notes
that was really good that was that was
very good
well i'm kind of
i'm happy we had to end on something
that was 11 to 10.
we did a lot of good work um
we were respectful
even in our differences
so thank you very much everybody
representative kanark i have just a
simple question you had made a comment
this morning i think that you wanted
our committee reports in writing i had
prepared them all as a
digital form that i was going to email
to you
may i still do that as long as i do it
this afternoon as long as you do it this
afternoon i'll take it in any format
that i can read good thank you um you'll
read a better digital form well yes i
know about doctor's hands writing but uh
if if you wish to stay and write it out
on any of them i'll stay here another 10
or 15 minutes
some people prefer that but we got to
have them this afternoon everybody thank
you
another thing that might be helpful
because we did i don't know maybe it's
maybe this is going to be too cumbersome
but just to make sure we haven't missed
anything because you are under the gun
it's not going to be easy for you to
contact somebody tonight and say hey
aren't you responsible for blah blah
blah could we just have
in the order in which our bills were a
quick rundown of who's responsible for
the reports just to make sure we haven't
forgotten anything i think i know mine
well i'm going to ask my vice chair if
she would take us on a journey to
blerbistan
okay
it's a russian soviet republic um
okay i'm going to go in time order guys
guys guys could we we're trying to this
is important there i mean not that
you're not but we got to have this
i'm going to go in time order
cushman and merchant
pearson and shapiro
10 45
oh sorry is there any way to oh you
can't do it
in this order
you're doing the order we did them yeah
i got it
slower
so if you're writing it i i'm sorry i
was doing it thinking that when people
would hear their name they would write
down that number well they will guys
they got to go a little bit uh
1244 merchant
this
because i've one this all out i need to
check if what you're saying is what i
have written down okay i'm sorry i was
getting thumbs up from the different
people who were the ones recognized
14.55 or give me a thumbs up when you're
and lucy you're good as well sorry
so i thought you were right checking
yours that's why i was trying to make
sure i wasn't moving too quickly for you
i said 1481 1455
1409 weber
thirteen forty seven
oh
oh perfect thank you then i will um i
will have that corrected um let me write
so sorry cofould is the minority on
1044.
okay
1347 cushman and kanerk
now we get to today
1290 salloway
perfect
13.79
pearson
because you know who to call when it
isn't written
one four three nine
leon and weber and i don't know the
one four three nine leon for the
majority webber for the minority but i
and i checked those off of the list i
yes 1347
yesterday
um
uh
is
an equation goes to zero what happens
science is a social
cultural
construct
and that's
just the epitome of this last
session
dare to have this discussion 20 years
ago
because of the impetus and because of
the ignorance
and i debated whether i should say
something
and i decided people probably didn't
want to hear me pontificate about they
don't know about science but maybe i
should have
and
every one of those individuals is a
female
absolutely yes
it's only if
if
regardless of what genetics is right
so
just take that now
well
we can still tell
no you can't
you may remember dick osbourne gave me
examples
um this was his story and i repaired
a commandant
um
so when you say just look at the
waterworks you know the doctor can tell
you
i'm
oh yeah
yes
oh
i'm heartbroken
i'm physically ill
i just
i can't imagine what's wrong i'm just
going to swap myself
all right by the way i have a question
for you yes sir were you ever told by
your friends
if there was a donation made to honor
you
no
oh okay
foreign
somehow
is
oh
you